[Musique]
donjon france d'en bas
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission qui kiffent sa
race avec nous ce soir jean marie bigard
[Musique]
josé bové la nouvelle vision des rois
jack lang
philippe meyer
lou doillon
et christine angot
peluches de blind test consacré ce soir
c'est normal
a météo
[Musique]
et pour commencer voici jean marie
bigard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean marc émond soir bonsoir j'adore ton
public les biens
thomas bonsoir
enfin merci d'avoir choisi tout le monde
en parle pour annoncer son nouveau
spectacle dont tu viens de nous montrer
la fiche so lu ment et dont on va parler
mais avant de parler de ton nouveau
spectacle je voulais qu'on regarde le
best-of de la semaine passée ça
s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé
magnéto serge et puis un jour ce jour
c'est le 11 septembre 2001 comme vous
dites
les [ __ ] ils ont pété mon bureau je
suis médusés je vois passer devant
devant mes fenêtres et des mes employés
sont médusés aussi on voit passer des
tonnes d'oeufs de morceaux de ferraille
de kérosène le vert et on sait pas ce
que c'est oui je suis sorti en
souterrain les gens qui sont sortis sur
le parvis et qui était parti en même
temps que moi
eux sont décédés le nuage tueur le
killer klout les nuages ce tueur est ce
que j'appellerais plus tard aussi
vraiment le baiser de la mort et c'est
parce que ça dépasse l'entendement en un
instant alors que dans cette rue il y
avait une vie extraordinaire de services
de secours qui étaient dans tous les
sens de voitures de d'ambulances de
gyrophares partout de sirène soudain
s'abat sur nous cette masse monstrueuse
et tout devient silencieux et c'est la
nuit pour ou contre le réchauffement de
la planète
au moment des vacances j'aime bien
est-ce que vous êtes franck dubosc pour
ou contre ces trentenaires qui chantent
ils aux enfants des soirées privées pour
bien sûr voici venu le temps des rires
je ne suis pas content non
[Applaudissements]
thébaux années difficiles aussi franck
parce que c'est l'année où vous avez
perdu votre votre père wima vu réussir
mais il a tout faux il a j'ai du mal à
parler de ça alors il n'a pas vu
l'olympia ouais donc ça ça vous vu des
réactions de lionel jospin n'ont
finalement apprécié les nets j'ose pas
en fait dans toute cette histoire c'est
vos allusions la taille de son sexe
qu'est ce que tu veux dire par un peu
court pour être président le matin quand
tu te regarde dans la glace
est ce que tu te dis ouais cool je suis
david hallyday
non non non je me dis pas ça non je me
dis que j'aurais mieux fait de dormir
deux heures de plus ça a été très
discret sur la famille ça va non non non
bien non
nickel tout va bien moi j'ai quand même
appris que johnny hallyday était ton
père est ce que j'ai décidé d'arrêter
des émissions de télé à la con non moi
je suis ici ce soir donc
donc non en fait je pars du principe que
je n'ai pas aimé les homosexuels et je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi c'est pour
moi les homosexuels n'existe pas
exactement comme les hétérosexuels
n'existe pas je considère qu'il a une
sexualité par personne que la communauté
homosexuelle c'est quelque chose qui
m'échappe comme si par exemple dans une
communauté des mecs à lunettes blond
avec des doubles foyer qui mettent des
baskets adidas et des piétons business
est-ce que des sosies de johnny hallyday
beaucoup non oui je connais ainsi johnny
hallyday qui m'a dit une phrase
inoubliable il m'a dit je suis bien
content que johnny se soit stabilisée
senti mentalement parce que j'arrive
plus à suivre du seconde excusez-moi
deux secondes je sais vraiment c'est
presque fini
excusez moi de ce que ce pardon excusez
moi excuses thierry ardisson bonsoir
excusez-moi d' interrompre
l'enregistrement d'émissions suis
vraiment désolé division vous apporter
la gloire
le pouvoir l'argent la réussite duquel
vous vous débarrasserez le plus
facilement aujourd'hui donc
[Musique]
jean marie bigard avant de parler de
spectacle
j'aimerais qu'on fasse le bilan du
précédent quand même parce que ça a été
un succès énorme arrêt combien de
spectateurs
sept cent mille à peu près à wissant
nouveau truc que je t'aime c'est
possible que ça convient de
représentation 334 un truc comme ça mais
comme une aventure extraconjugale bros
pratiquement aucune en tout cas pas de
pénétration non non et des caresses des
fois un peu mais
[Musique]
quand même aimé le gros plan sur le
visage pendant le cunnilingus perd quand
même bénéfices
c'est énorme sur le cac comme quoi quand
et demandent eux ne répond rien c'est
rare en tous les cas qu un showman de
haut niveau revienne aussi vite sur
scène non j'avais une idée surtout sur
sublime quoi les dix animaux et des
hommes toi donc c'était une idée qui
était depuis longtemps dans ma tête de
me dire j'avais lu cette phrase que
l'homme est l'animal le plus évolué de
la planète et qui devrait s'en féliciter
chaque matin se dire je suis en pole
position de la chaîne animal
ouais ça m'a tellement fait rire parce
que je me suis dit on est battus souvent
par l'animal est haut et voilà c'est
venu c'est venu très vite et j'avais une
mine d'or en devant moi et plus qu'à
taper dedans donc je me suis dit
pourquoi attendre alors jean marie quand
je t'ai demandé des informations sur son
nouveau spectacle
voilà ce que ma fac c'est jean marie
bigard mais voilà le nouveau spectacle
de jean marie bigard alors je vais te
filer puis à partir de ça tu fais ici
nous et moi je remplissais c'est vrai
pierrick j'étais donné ça c'est pas une
blague de ce code le matin où j'ai écrit
ça j'avais j'avais pondu mon spectacle
j'ai dit voilà mon spectacle il est là
c'est quoi les trois trucs quand il a la
balle et trois grandes différences etc
l'homme par rapport à l'animal c'est un
scientifique un guinea ça c'est pas moi
qui le dis c'est que l'homme à la
conscience de sa conscience il peut pas
dire qu'il n'a pas il a un il a un
langage articulé complet c'est énorme ça
s'il peut dire où il a mal quand s'il a
eu mal et puis troisième truc
l'homme sait qui va mourir ça c'est pas
un super avantages qu'un instinct animal
mais l'animal lui ne sait pas qui va
mourir j'ai un bon dernier moment c'est
étonnant alors organisation sociale
c'est quoi par exemple alors à braives a
évidemment les grands chapitres
l'organisation sociale c'est entre les
animaux les hommes
tu voyais les grands la vie en groupe on
vient groupes comme les animaux on a des
patrons les animaux ont des chefs de
meute
la famille la migration la communication
à sang rouge par exemple c'est quoi
parce que le poisson rouge lui par
contre il se fait pas chier dans le
bocal basse que il a que trois secondes
de mémoire ah bon le bressan rouge n'a
que trois secondes de même c'est vrai ça
ça va vite non mais c'est authentique 1
1 on a déterminé qu'il est les trois
grands novices et jamais chier tu vois
par exemple attendant je vous le fais tu
peux tu peux
c'était pas prévu mais je vous le faites
en juin donc le poisson rouge
il est dans le bocal par exemple ils
s'engueulent avec sa bonne femme tu me
fais chier tube fichiers j'ai perdu mon
pote fredj un contrôle fiscal au cul tu
fais chier c'est un tour de bocal ya un
audit a pensé à appeler fred pour
bouffer on a des nouvelles d abu fait un
tour jorat dame
sympa cette abarth un t'as vu le buffet
sympa cet appart à vue buffet
c'est merci et la migration ses voix
écoute j'ai écrit ce spectacle avec
laurent baffie je veux dire mon laurent
baffie mon petit frère parce qu'il est
vachement pointues sur les animaux se
connaît et on s'est régalé parce que il
ya un moment toi je dis moi qu'un joueur
des centaines de milliers d'oiseaux
comme ça qu'ils partent en même temps au
même moment toi comme ça toi me dis il
ya bien un couple ou deux dans la bande
qui a pas envie d'y aller a joué
j'imagine les deux femelles qui
discutent ils disent de moins avec
raymond je sais pas si on va y aller
cette année je veux dire si c'est peu
ctp 17 mille bornes comme l'année
dernière un arrivée ruines et de fatigue
sur un rocher couvert de merde si c'est
pour se taper les martineau comme
l'année dernière avec leurs gosses qui
piaillent et ben moi je sais pas si on
va y aller avec ya les saumons les
saumons les deux semaines ouais alors
une elle dit à l'hôtel dix mois déjà
nouvelles frontières plus jamais hyper
mal flécher le parcours on a tourné dans
l'estuaire deux heures au milieu des
bateaux à votre trouver le fleuve après
on a remonté 400 bornes à contre courant
je passe tu vois la galère alors et en
plus l'accueil là-bas excuse-moi de
kilomètres de l'arrivée ghislaine ses
prêts une grande tarte dans la gueule
par un ours
il n'y avait rien fait elle même pas
regardé rien il aurait voulu la bouffe
et s'y serait pas pris autrement
et dire on est arrivé j'étais fatigué
fatigué j'avais plus qu'une envie
c'était d'accoucher et de repartir même
maurice ils avaient plus envie de rien
la preuve j'ai été obligé de le branle
et au dessus d eux
les changements cette trentenaire je
savais pas que le mérou au bout de cinq
ans il passait deux femelles à mal voilà
la daurade celle inverse elle passe de
mâts la femelle c'est vrai il y en a et
c'est tout à fait authentique
là vous pouvez vérifier vous faites
internet par exemple il ya un poisson
qui s'appelle le barbier houle à
castagnolles rouge tu vois tout un
programme
lui il passe demain la femelle mais pas
uniquement en fonction de la croissance
mais quand il ya trop de mal dans le
troupeau alors moi j'ai fait la fête de
la castagne rouge c'est à la fin de
l'année le baby eastwood il fait un il
allait dire excusez moi interrompre la
fête de la castagne rouge mais bon vous
avez vu cette année il ya un petit peu
trop de mecs
donc je vous annonce une bonne nouvelle
il ya jean raymond ici qui a décidé
spontanément de changer de sexe le goal
applaudi jean-raymond niola glamour h
saeedi jean-raymond aiguë a été un des
plus grands ni coeur de la bande en est
fière de toi on est vraiment ému alors
tu sais ce qu'on va faire on va boire un
dernier verre entre potes et après entre
bourg
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ces spectacles donc c ou c kan
s'est tourné de rodage comme d'habitude
je pars faire un petit tour de france
une quarantaine de dates
après je fais une dizaine de zenit en
descente du 10 au 18 décembre et ensuite
j 9 un petit peu parce que je veux pas
faire toi tout paris et toute la
province après donc je fais tout en même
temps c'est à dire qu' après je serai
présent trois jours par mois au zénith
de paris et dans toute la france donc je
fais je fais tout en même temps ça rend
pas mégalo comme ça de haranguer d'aidé
foule de plusieurs milliers de personnes
avec la voix booster avec son image sur
des écrans géants c'est tellement c'est
une scène c'est une drogue dure mais en
même temps comme c'est le métier que
j'avais choisi ce à peu près le seul
truc que je sais faire mais à m'en
apporte beaucoup de pognon
j'ai du mal à penser le côté non mais
évidemment c'est super grisant ce qui
est super grise en c2 de savoir que tu
as pu attraper plein de gens en même
temps et surtout que toi je discute avec
eux avec francis veber qui est un un
maître dans l'art d'écrire et il dit moi
que je lis aussi mes scénarios aux gens
physiquement je sens si je les fais
chier ou pas un toit par exemple là je
viens de faire des trucs sur le plateau
tous et pas l'endroit du tout pour le
faire et des housses et roxy
non mais c'est pas ça mais c'est pas
pratique j'ai des tas des gens dans le
dos était au machin tu sais pas
exactement comment le réalisateur tac
adressa se trouve d'après juste l'oeil
au moment où tu faisais ça toi il a pris
juste sa voix par yves herman mais lui
il a bien fait je suis sûr mais bon tu
sais pas mais même en faisant ça et même
dans ces conditions là je sais qu'il ya
deux trois trucs par exemple je vais
coller un peu plus de ce que j'ai fait
chier tu sens dans l'oeil si tu fais
chier ou pas l'aude et je crois que
c'est comme ça qu'on fait ou qu'on fait
pas une belle carrière c'est quand on a
le souci de ce qu'on donne à l'autre
mais tu le test avec les copains toute
la journée tout le temps tout le temps
je suis incapable en ce moment par
exemple de faire autre chose à un dîner
que la moitié de mon spectacle
si je fais chier un seul homme tout le
monde je suis obligé de changer de potes
tous les soirs parce qu'ils en ont
jusque là ne connaissent par coeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donner
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant
là
voici josé bové groshaeny
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
m
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir jean françois dufour vice
président d'attac et aussi confédération
paysanne comme josé bové alors josé bové
il ya trois ans vous deveniez subitement
célèbre en détruisant un mcdonald's en
construction à l'entrée de milo pour
protester contre les taxes américaines
imposés au roquefort français
c'est vrai qu'en fait au moment où le
mcdo a été démonté vous étiez en train
de donner une interview à fr3 tout à
fait j'étais à l'extérieur par des
montées en fait ce que je ne suis jamais
rentré à l'intérieur du bateau sauf à
l'est rien pour dire aux gens de sortir
alors votre incarcération préventive et
votre procès pendant l'été 2000 vous ont
transformé en star mondiale je dirais
mondialisée personnage du gaulois
moustachu reçu aussi bien par marcos k
davos et cet été vous êtes retourné en
prison pour purger votre peine et
finalement ça a été moins un événement
ça peut empêcher chirac devait partir en
vacances quoi je pense que pas mal de
gens étaient sous le coup de ces trois
mois d'élections de ces espèces de
péripéties de ce 21 avril
cauchemardesque et c'est vrai que les
gens étaient lassés et personnes
s'attendaient ni dans les organisations
syndicales ni dans aucun mouvement est
ce qu'une telle chose puisse se passer
donc je crois que les gens étaient tous
surpris et avant que les choses se
mettent en route et bien c'est vrai que
le mois et demi de prison est passé mais
parce qu à quoi ça sert de se faire
mettre en prison ça fait pas la une des
médias d'une certaine façon non c'est
pas moi qui ai choisi d'aller révision
c'est quand même d'abord un tribunal qui
m'a condamné un autre tribunal qui a
reçu renchéri et pour finir un procureur
qui a décidé de l'incarcérer à la
prochaine phase et pour 14 mois
j'attends cette décision de la cour de
cassation ouais et si la décision est la
même que celle de la cour d'appel est
bien normal manger 14 mois de prison à
effectuer est mesurée par rapport
c'est démesuré c'est le seul pays où les
où ce genre de protestataires sont
traités comme ça peut-être aux états
unis maintenant ça coince aussi un peu
on dirait qu'à une petite analogie lac
est en train de se passer quoi alors
croyez pas que vous avez été victime
quand même de deux choses d'abord une
médiatisation à outrance ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la guignolisation c'est
à dire qu'à un moment vous êtes devenu
une espèce de caricatures de vous même
avec les moustaches la pipe comme ça
d'ailleurs j'ai un mail
on a des mails pour les invités de la
semaine suivante il suffit de regarder
sur sur le site tout le monde en parle
un mail de stéphane à pierre bénite près
de lyon qui dit en fait que vous avez
été récupéré par les médias et que vous
incarnez désormais un personnage
médiatique parmi d'autres celui
d'agitateurs celle que récupéré par la
société vous avez votre rôle sinon vous
êtes devenu un rouage comme un autre
effectivement les médias ont un
fonctionnement assez curieux que j'ai eu
le temps d'analyser depuis trois ans
c'est à dire que en général ils prennent
quelqu'un qui est dans l'actualité il
fonde un fait quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
sans se rendre compte que c'est quelque
chose qui est construit depuis des
années ouais
et puis au bout d'un certain temps comme
le phénomène continue à durer parce que
cette bagarre c'est une bagarre londres
contre cette mondialisation néolibérale
est bien certain nombre de médias en ont
assez ils disent maintenant ça suffit on
n'en parle plus comme l'effet continu
ils sont obligés d'en reparler alors ça
monte ça descend ça remonte ça descend
et on se retrouve dans une situation
assez compliqués entre les gens qui
agissent et qui font l'actualité et ceux
qui en parlent qui voudraient décider en
fait qu'est ce qui fait l'actualité
et donc là il ya un rapport tout à fait
curieux et je pense que les choses sont
en train de bouger parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se rendent compte
qu'il faut que les choses changent à ce
niveau là alors josé bové je disais donc
victime des médias et aussi de la
sévérité des institutions qui sont
implacables quoi parce que vous êtes
quand même retrouver en taule alors bon
c'est vrai qu'en retard avec votre
tracteur comme ça c'était assez
folklorique mais vous en parler plus
tristement c'est à dire que la nuit vous
entendiez des hurlements enfin je dirais
vécu l'univers carcéral même si c'était
dans l'hérault c'est vrai que l'univers
carcéral c'est quelque chose de
parfaitement inhumain
les personnes sont détruites en prison
c'est à dire qui est une dignité à
l'intérieur d'une prison
on est plus qu'un cas matricule et en
même temps la personne ne peut pas se
reconstruire donc quand on sort de
prison où on devient un récidiviste mais
dans tous les cas on déteste la société
dans sa pose une question à quoi sert la
prison dans ces cas là et c'est vrai que
j'entendais hurler toute la nuit il ya
eu un bruit permanent dans les prisons
les gens hurlent souvent par l' angoisse
vous qui êtes contre la malbouffe en
prison c'est le terrible non en prison
l'alimentation c'est quelque chose c'est
un vrai cauchemar en cuisine on tient là
en plus dans ces prisons modernes c'est
géré par le privé mal géré
mental privé le privé charles la bouffe
gère l'entretien gère la construction et
donc si on veut continuer en plus c'est
encore le privé et or là les prix là
c'est pas le supermarché c'est vraiment
les prix prohibitifs terre que celui qui
a du fric il peut se payer quelque chose
et donc là c'est quelque chose qui est
parfaitement inacceptable c'est dire
qu'à l'intérieur de la prison c'est la
société mais en pire
si tu veux diffusio logique non mais je
sais c'est vrai que donc la prison et
duke en fait à la au rapport de force
ce qui est dramatique c'est que les
détenus en fait là dedans sont
complètement perdus parce qu'ils ont
aucun espoir
je veux dire que les surveillances de la
même manière aujourd'hui sont
complètement déboussolés
parce qu'en fait c'est eux qui doivent
assumer la responsabilité du système
pénitentiaire alors que les politiques
en fait s'en lave les mains très peu de
politiques vont dans les prisons alors
que c'est quelque chose à quoi il ya
deux ans mais ça c'est bien
ils vont comme client qui est quand même
intéressant à savoir
moi j'ai parlé de la france du sous sol
parce que ce sont des gens qui n'existe
plus il ya de plus de 50000 personnes
aujourd'hui qui n'existe plus c'est pas
la france d'en bas c'est la france c'est
la france du sous-sol celle dont on ne
parle paix et simplement ce qui est
dramatique c'est que ce ne sont pas
simplement les détenus qui sont en
prison mais leurs familles aussi sont en
prison parce qu'en fait tout est fait
pour déshumaniser la personne et au bout
d'un certain temps certaines familles
n'osent même plus aller voir le détenu
est donc assez tragique parce qu'en fait
c'est tout le monde qui est détruit par
la prison alors c'est pas à cause de la
mal bouffe que vous avez fait votre
grève de la faim quand même non j'ai
décidé de jeûner pendant 25 jours en
solidarité avec les gens qui étaient à
l'extérieur qu'ils continuaient le
combat avec le mouvement social pour
dire que même si on m'avait privé de ma
liberté et j'avais encore le droit
d'accepter ou de refuser de manger gras
ça a marché vous avez perdu combien je
n'ai pas fait pour maigrir mais il
s'avère que vous parlez josé bové de
criminalisation du mouvement social
je crois que pudiquement ce qui s'est
passé cet été très grave
au delà de mon incarcération il ya eu le
débat sur la loi d amnistie et pour la
première fois en france depuis la
libération
il ya une loi d'amnistié votée qui
exclut tout l'effet syndicaux l'effet
collectif la récidive
tout ce qui est fait
et dans une action syndicale a été
retiré purement et simplement de la loi
des mici mais ça c'est raffarin là ce
que ce que vous dites là c'est à dire
cette criminalisation des rapports c'est
très clairement aujourd'hui une volonté
du gouvernement de monsieur raffarin de
vraiment de casser le mouvement
revendicatif la défense des droits la
défense des sans des sans papiers des
sans travail des sans logis aujourd'hui
il ya un véritable mouvement répressif
qui est en train de se mettre en place
il faut pas qu'il faut plus qu'il ya une
tête qui dépasse josé bové le discours
super écolo de jacques chirac à
johannesburg
ça vous a bien énervé j'imagine en sait
quelque chose de parfaitement
inacceptable on peut pas à la fois dire
on va défendre les paysans du sud et en
même temps dire il faut absolument qu'on
maintienne aux subventions aux
exportations
c'est un vrai c'est un scandale je vois
que des types comme ça devrait être
poursuivie pour de tels propos
le présent à un public clair ah oui
d'accord mais la communité lui donc il
reste que rien benarroch par exemple lui
dis ça les autres disent rien du tout
c'est à dire les risques peuvent
poursuivre et les autres disent rien du
tout abc païlin qui m'aiment bien
revenir il a quand même nom mais il a
quand même les couilles de tenir un
discours que les autres ne tiennent pas
du tout quoi et mais je crois que ce qui
est grave c'est qu'est figure est
considéré un peu quand même pas le
[Musique]
bien sûr vous n'êtes pas allez vous non
je suis paris j'ai préféré aller aux
journées d'été d'attac
donc on s'est échangé françois
l'internât johannesburg et moi je suis
allée attaque d'accord ça sert à rien
d'y aller pour vous je pense que cette
fois ci se servait rien c'est ce que
j'ai dit déjà la veille du sommet le
sommet n'allait servir à rien parce
qu'en fait les véritables décisions
elles ne se prennent pas là elles se
prennent à l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
et là tout avait été cadré à deux doigts
pour que les pays du sud reste dans la
merde et pour que rien ne change
alors josé bové françois dufour c'est
déjà écrit ensemble le monde n'est pas
une marchandise éditions de la
découverte et vous publié aujourd'hui le
grain de l'avenir c'est chez plon
[Musique]
le métier après le monde est pas une
marchandise d'essayer d'apporter un peu
plus d'informations encore aux citoyens
aux gens qui habitent dans les villes et
qui malheureusement sont de plus en plus
coupés du monde paysan et de la réalité
de l'agriculture donc on essaie on a
essayé à travers ce livre d'apporter à
nouveau quelques réponses pour que les
gens comprennent ce qui est en train de
se passer
page 41 vous dit en parlant de l'
alimentation diversifiée à moins de
manger tous demain des pilules et des
crèmes nutritive fabriqué dans une
agro-industrie est distribué dans de
nouvelles halles aseptisé en forme de
terminale au centre de mes gars bill
science-fiction complète vrai pas que
j'exagère un petit peu là je pense qu'on
est on est sur ce chemin là c'est
d'ailleurs une grande partie de
l'alimentation qu'on trouve en ville
aujourd'hui ce sont des ersatz de
produits agricoles
on voit bien que de plus en plus par la
grande distribution c'est une
alimentation standardisés complètement
industrialisés qui était la portée des
personnes et je crois que là il ya un
véritable sursaut à voir c'est dire que
si on veut remettre en cause cette
logique qui est en train de détruire
l'environnement qui est en train de
détruire la qualité des produits il faut
changer à la fois le mode de d'épicerie
bution et puis le mode de production des
aliments à vous dénoncer à nouveau le
culte du progrès technologique
vous dites que finalement la finalité de
tout ça c'est pas de nourrir la planète
mais finalement c'est c'est la technique
je crois qu'il ya une logique infernale
aujourd'hui ou quand la technique peut
faire quelque chose
elle va jusqu'au bout c'est là qu'il ya
pas de réflexion sur la finalité du
projet la question des organismes
génétiquement modifiés et complètement
évidente par rapport à ça oui ce qui
m'intéresse là dedans c'est que j'aurai
savoir moi ce que vous pensez
l'utilisation des engrais le fait de
creuser la terre j'ai lu l'autre jour un
truc qui disait que maintenant la
charrue qui creusent à 40 cm la terre tu
à coup sûr toutes les bestioles qui
vivent entre 10 et 15 centimètres sous
terre et qui donc qui participent aux
hélicos éléments et au que la plante va
dans la blonde va se nourrir leur la
graine va se nourrir
tu mets tout ça les couilles à l'air sur
le dos avec le soleil du dessèche donc
la terre tu remets de l'engrais burgess
soit fertile mais en fait on appauvrit
l'ensemble et on fait une nourriture qui
est de moins bonne
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en fait il
ya une minorité d'agriculteurs dans le
monde qui utilisent cette technologie de
pointe qui sont en train de détruire le
maximum des terres puisque je rappelle
juste un chiffre consiste en le livre il
ya que 28 millions de paysans dans le
monde qui ont un tracteur il y en a 250
millions qui travaille avec la traction
animale et 1 milliard 300 millions qui
travaillait à la main donc aujourd'hui
le désert sous la neige c'est les choses
sont jouables c'est changer la loge est
simplement est ce que tu t'es mon
spectacle ça va vous revenir là-dessus
mais je suis tombé sur un truc qui dit
que c'est étonnant quand même parce que
la terre à 450 milliards d'années et que
les cent dernières années on a fait 70%
de la pollution actuelle est décerné à
nos 100 dernières années qui représente
même pas un cheveu sur l'échelle de la
vie humaine en cent ans on a fait 70% de
la pollution actuelle ce extraordinaire
et dans les dix chaînes dans les 10
prochaines années si on continue de
faire moins de la moitié de la
biodiversité de la planète aura disparu
si on continue le système c'est vrai que
j'ai c'est vrai que ça chauffe
réellement tâche aussi aux palmas
exemple et d'inondations est comme ça et
il n'y a pas de hasard
il a chaque fois tous les scientifiques
nous le disent bien le réchauffement la
bête va faire que wii play pleuvra de
plus en plus et wii fait c'est qu'il
pleuvra de moins en moins justement
c'est évident et que les lieux les
inondations et les pauvres malheureuse
famille côté inondé dévasté tout le
match et fauqué il faut pas s'attendre à
ce que ça aille mieux que dans les dix
prochaines années ça soit mieux non les
crues sont de plus en plus forte
donc il a est paraît il faut agir vite
et puis il faut surélevé tout le monde
de deux étages que nous avons voulu dans
ce livre c'est tirait bien sur le bilan
de ce qui ne marche pas et de toute la
politique agricole telle qu elle a été
orientée de la dénonciation que nous en
faisons
mais en contrepartie à partir de nos
propres exemple et de ce que nous
voulons engager comme débat de société
avec la société de ce que doit être
l'agriculture demain dans cette deuxième
partie du lit nous apportons
concrètement un certain nombre de
solutions et en même temps alors un des
phénomènes majeurs donc très peu de
monde parle
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
au niveau des abeilles c'était là qu'on
est en train d'assister à la destra
action des abeilles un peu partout sur
le territoire
à cause de l'utilisation de produits
chimiques notamment le gaucho un produit
qui est fait pas une très belle firme
bayer agrochimique et aujourd'hui on
n'arrive absolument pas donc les
scientifiques l'ont prouvé on n'arrive
absolument pas faire interdire les
produits de la firme bayer cela fait un
bail est en même temps une grosse boîte
faire lorsque l'abeille votants à une
technologie formidable c'est un
industriel il est nommé à la rien changé
elle pollue pas fait son boulot elle
nous donne du miel données de miel
puisqu'elle permet de polliniser aussi
énormément d'armes absolument région il
y aura plus de gens regard appuyé là
mais si je ne sais pas si vous savez un
truc que j'ai étudié c'est que la bei se
fait tirer en plein vol la reine se fait
tirer chapeau si vous saviez ça mais je
vous pose la question sérieusement se
fait tirer en plein vol pendant deux
jours par une cinquantaine de mal non
mais sans déconner influent de la guerre
et elle range dans sa spermathèque
personnel le sperme des 50 mal et après
quand elle l'est dans la ruche et
qu'elle devient la reine elle donne donc
naissance à des milliers de 40000 ou
cinquante mille petites abeilles qui ont
la même mère et qui sont de 50 pères
différents est d'ailleurs le mal et il
tirait il laisse les
les couilles et la [ __ ] sur le truc
d'ailleurs parce qu'il peut pas se
retire qui tirait immer tire son coup en
plein vol comme un vulgaire stewart
[Applaudissements]
après je pressens gagne
les abeilles et c'est dégueulasse quand
tu la petite abeille bien josé bové vous
ne serez pas étonnés quand vous fasse
une interview fromage ou dessert
[Musique]
attention josé bové est ce que vous
préféreriez un week-end dans le loft ou
en prison en prison il apparaît flexi
non adéquation
pourquoi parce que le loft ça me fait
gerber il complète plus que la prison
encore encore plus de pression parce que
même en prison j'ai même pas regardé les
deux
est ce que vous préférez aller manger
chez mcdo ou en prison
je préfère je n'ai est ce que vous
préférez les belles voitures ou les
beaux tracteurs g ni l'un ni l'autre
donc je fais avec préféré quand vous
coupe la moustache ou la parole ça ne me
gêne pas qu'on me coupe la parole
ouais je suis habitué vous préférez la
prison pour les enfants de 13 ans ou la
liberté pour les présidents de 69 ans je
pense que ce que je préfère c'est
l'abolition de la prison pour tout le
monde et on fera comment je pense qu'on
n'a pas besoin de prison il ya d'autres
méthodes pour faire en sorte de réparer
parce que la prison ne répare absolument
pas les dédits la prison parc des gens
pour un certain temps et puis après une
fois commis un meurtre en fait quoi
je pense qu'il ya d'autres systèmes que
la prison la prison a aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas simplement un enfermement une
privation de liberté c'est la négation
de la personne et je crois que donc par
rapport à ça il faut changer
radicalement 16 modes d'enfermement vous
préférez la coiffure de luc ferry ou son
projet pour l'éducation nationale je
préfère de dos vous préférez que les
ministres soient augmenté de 70 % qu'ils
prennent directement à la caisse
je préférerais qu'on augmente le smic
on a fait un petit peu un monte le smic
combien je peux combien 15 pour cent
vingt neuf à 25,2 de 2,2 non pas 2 6 2 %
et 2 % ce qui était une solution
moi je trouve ça vraiment
ce qu'on a vu que un mec qui bosse je
veux dire un truc terrible
un mec qui veut de deux tiers des
travailleurs qui gagnent donc un smic
qui tourne autour de 6 enfants un peu
vrai et que on est très bien organisé en
matière de protection sociale pour
quelqu'un qui n'a plus de travail avec
les apl les machins moi je le sais parce
que je m'en occupe
et je suis toujours un petit peu choqué
de voir qu'il ya à peine mille francs de
différence entre un mec protéger
normalement un gars qui a des papiers je
parle 1 et qui a une apl et qu'un machin
ya presque il ya presque 1000 ou 1500
mal de différences entre un mec qui
grattent et un gars kinky à ses papiers
qui est en fin de droits
et moi je trouve que moi si j'avais été
au gouvernement j'aurais fait ce qui a
été fait un jour c'est d'augmenter de
30% le smic tout le monde avait crié au
scandale dit ça marchera pas et tout
mais je crois que ça résoudrait pas mal
de problèmes
si on mettait le carrément si on
augmente explique de 30%
c'est à dire que entre quelqu'un qui
travaille quelqu'un qui travaille pas
qui est une réelle différence risque et
la protection et je dis que ça serait ça
serait bien faisons le de 30% d'accor
tout le monde est d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'essaie
josé bové j'aurais pu également vous
demandez dans l'interview fromage
dessert si vous préfériez harel sharon
ou yasser arafat
je pense que je les choses sont claires
il y en a un qui est victime d'une
colonisation et l'autre qui est en train
d'envahir un territoire qui ne lui
appartient pas donc je parle que les
choses sont claires le 2 avril après
votre retour de ramallah en palestine
vous avez été accusé d'antisémitisme
pour avoir fait deux choses d'abord
nazifié le comportement d'israël en
utilisant les mots rafle camps
d'internement mirador qui rappelle
effectivement la shoah et deuxièmement
insinué que le mossad les services
secrets israéliens
mettez des bombes devant les synagogues
pour en parler avec nous ce soir voici
guy que l'appli qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est que ma petite fille bonsoir
donc vous êtes auteur entre autres d'un
livre qui est sorti la saison dernière
qui s'appelle la faute des juges ça
tombe bien chez balland vous avez été
choqué quand josé bové est rentré en
france et que après son voyage en
palestine il a employé les mots comme
raf le mirador camps d'internement quand
il a supposé que le mossad mettait des
bombes devant les synagogues évidemment
évidemment j'ai été choqué et j'ai même
envie de dire doublement choqué c'est à
dire que quand qu'en gros bornes fait un
calembour monstrueux ça me choque ça me
met en colère
j'ai envie de me battre mais j'ai rien à
voir avec lui quand c'est josé bové qui
parle je partage pas mal de valeur
beaucoup de combats qu'il a et il
incarne qu'il mène et voilà que
brusquement sur cette situation là quand
il ya eu des centaines d'actes anti juif
en france sous prétexte de ce conflit du
proche orient il dit mais c'est le
mossad le mossad c'est un mythe
formidable c'est le complot juif
il redit d'ailleurs il a choisi un
excellent journal pour faire une
autocritique ce qu'est ce qui est
toujours très bien c'était oui auquel je
collabore donc c'est évidemment être mon
jour là et c'est d'abord très bien de
dire je m'excuse j'ai été piégé
c'est quand même je reconnais ça mais au
milieu de sa up on retrouve le mossad et
on a l'impression que si des juifs ont
dû quitter des pays comme la syrie ou
comme l'irak c'est parce qu'il ya eu des
manipulations mais non tu avais parce
que dès l'instant où il ya eu c'est ce
que dsk dit josé bové pour être clair
pour nos amis téléspectateurs à ce que
dit josé bové dans son article vous
faites une sorte de mea culpa
vous dites que c'est le mossad qui avait
organisé disons des attentats à bagdad
en 51 au maroc en egypte pour favoriser
le retour des juifs de la diaspora en
israël c'est prouvé ça il y a eu il y a
eu c'est le mossad on lui a toujours
prêté énormément de choses il se trouve
qu'un pays constamment en guerre à des
services secrets et qu'ils prennent trop
d'importance
il se trouve aussi qu'il est arrivé
qu'un gouvernement israélien parce que
c'est une démocratie tombe parce qu'il
avait utilisé le mossad pour
une petite affaire en syrie ou en
accélérer le départ des juifs mais il se
trouve aussi que ça c'est 51 52 que lis
les émeutes antijuives dans le monde
arabe commence dès l'instant où les
juifs nadal ou les juifs s'installent
donc c'est ça complètement et de dribble
c'est gai c'est que c'est pas
complètement fait un million de juifs
ont dû quitter le monde arabe
c'est pas à cause de deux trois petits
trucs organisé ici ici ou là je sais
comment on répondait là dessus je crois
que le contexte
quand j'ai parlé de deux camps
d'internement j'ai parlé de ce que j'ai
vu c'est à dire de civils palestiniens
qui étaient entourés de barbelés avec
effectivement des miradors des hommes en
armes et des projecteurs parce que
c'était de nuit et ces gens là qui
étaient là d'autres centaines de
palestiniens de ramallah puisque c'était
pas loin de ramallah qui était
agenouillée les mains attachées dans le
dos les yeux bandés en train d'attendre
d'être interrogé sa gelée eu parce que
j'étais gêné fait que décrire une
situation et j'ai employé justement des
termes qui soient les plus neutre
possible
je n'ai jamais employer de termes autre
que cela parce que ce sont ceux qu'on
emploie dans tous les conflits là où
j'ai effectivement fait une erreur où je
me suis trompé et je l'ait reconnu
effectivement parce que je pense que
c'est quelque chose de dont il faut
parler il faut le dire quand on se
trompe et je pense qu'on n'a jamais
toujours raison et c'est vrai que je
suis rentrée le 2 avril de palestine
après avoir été expulsé par l'armée
israélienne de ramallah et là j'arrive
dans un contexte complètement différent
en france
je me fais agresser à l'aéroport par des
groupes extrémistes le betar et dodeman
malgré taux qui se réclament de la
politique de monsieur sharon mais c'est
pas ça le problème
quand je rentre en palestine de
palestine je n'ai que je ne connais pas
l'émotion qui saisit la communauté juive
par rapport à ce qui vient de se passer
ça fait plusieurs ça fait longtemps que
je suis parti et je n'ai pas je ne vois
pas ce qui se passe et donc je parle
d'un certain nombre de choses et je
parle de cette histoire de 1951 de
bagdad de ces quelques faits et
effectivement le raccourci qui est
repris dans la presse laisse à penser
que jamal gamme
la politique du mossad avec les
événements qui vient de se passer
ce discours n'est pas compréhensible par
des gens qui sont en souffrance c'est
faux surtout je dis que ce n'est pas
qu'on principe parce que effectivement
ce n'est pas une réalité est que la
façon dont ces raccourcis donne
l'impression que je suis en train de
dire que le mossad a fait des attentats
en france
évidemment je n'ai jamais dit ça je n'ai
jamais pensé mais on a pu le comprendre
et je comprends moi que des jambes et
puis sentir blessés par rapport à cela
est ce que je voyais que je trouve
extraordinaire mais c'est qu'un pays
entier dont un qui arrive quelque part
avec une armée qui envahit qui décide
contre la terre entière qui est dit non
faut arrêter et qui dit ce pays dit non
on arrêtera quand on aura envie
d'arrêter
quel autre pays peut faire ça quel autre
pays peut faire ça je dire et puis quand
on bombe c'est comme si nous on bombarde
est un fps toi c'est à dire à 10 bornes
de là on bombarde f-16 et
translationnelle et j'ai rien dit
jusqu'à maintenant parce que j'étais
seul bloc et drôle de la lys et oui mais
je veux dire que comment comment est ce
que des hommes comment est ce que les
hommes intelligents et organisés peuvent
penser qu'on peut lutter contre des
individualités
les récits impossible de lutter un mec
décider qui a décidé de donner sa vie
vaut une armée entière
cette guerre ne peut pas être gagnée on
peut pas les américains ont compris
qu'ils se faisaient descendre les deux
tours du world trade center
avec douze mecs décidé quatre capteurs
la plus grosse armée du monde
personne ne peut rien faire contre un
mec a décidé de donner sa vie et donc
effectivement si jamais on dit baye à un
gosse de 17 ans qui s'est fait péter la
gueule en tuant un certain nombre aussi
d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants nous le
prendre une arme et on va attaquer alors
qu'on peut gagner cette guerre n'est pas
gagnant jean marc gosses de 17 ans ce
gosse de 17 ans il y a des gens qui
donnent de l'argent à sa famille il y a
des gens qui lui donne la ceinture de
bombes
ces gens là ont des noms ce sont des
organisations certaines basé en arabie
saoudite
ce sont des états la syrie l'irak se
sont une partie des dirigeants ce
palestinien
c'est l'autorité palestinienne elle-même
qui a détourné le fric
d'humanitaire le fric de la communauté
européenne pour pour fanatisés des
gosses pour fanatisés des gosses pour
les armées pour downing grimont me
raconter de me le prix moyen devrait
contenter seulement la maladie sa part
battre ça parce qu'on ne sait pas ce
combat parce que vous gardiez sais pas
ce que vous croyez que le terrorisme
libérateur en réalité le clan des jeunes
jeune fille je n'ai jamais dit ça je me
dis que 4 c'est ça ou rien du tout il
arrive que ce soit sera non il arrive
par exemple que l'on puisse à force
d'être d'un cas un peuple à force d'être
de savoir que de toute façon il n'a
jamais rien on peut arriver à ça la
preuve c'est qu'on n'y est il ya des
parents qui éduquent leurs enfants en
leur disant si tu te fais péter la
gueule en tuant d'autres personnes tu
seras un héros
elle ne me dites pas que ça peut pas
arriver parce que c'est ce qui se passe
oui c'est ce qui serait ce que pour
lutter contre ça une armée ne luttera
m'attendais à ce type en les amenant à
regagnera contre ce terrorisme n'a ni
panier pour défendre les palestiniens
ce terrorisme là c'est développer ou un
moment au moment où il y avait des
accords pour que ces accords n'y pas
lieu
bien qu'elle vous me parlez des gens
c'est en une poignée temps des gens
simplement de parler d'une poignée
d'étudiants qui s'entendent sur des
accords moi je vous parle de dé les
gosses qui depuis cinq générations
aucune idée en tête c'est de se faire
péter la gueule mais s'est creusé ces
deux décès formidable qu'il aura été
décrit leur a délivré un non dit
attendre on en est là moi je vous dis
pas que je préfère
comment ce qui est ce que vous croyez
sérieusement que c'est votre job
au delà de tout ça votre job avoue josé
bové qui défendent est un certain nombre
de valeurs ici en france et en europe
d'aller en palestine pour vous occuper
du problème israélo palestinien c'est
tout si je suis d'abord allé en
palestine
j'ai deux lettres en palestine pour le
30 mars parce que le 30 mars c'est la
journée de la terre qui est une fête des
paysans palestiniens pour commémorer un
massacre qui avait été fait par l'armée
israélienne en 1967 et depuis cette date
tous les ans il ya un grand
rassemblement des paysans palestiniens
et si nous sommes allés à ramallah à la
demande de ces paysans qui nous ont dit
l'armée israélienne va envahir ramallah
il serait important que vous soyez là
parce qu'on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer il faut des témoins
internationale en question à françois
dufour au sommet de durban
quand même les antimondialistes vous
faites partis ont comparé le sionisme à
un crime est ce que finalement il n'y a
pas là un terreau intellectuelle
philosophique qui peut expliquer des
positions comme celles qui ont été
prises par josé bové plus tard ce que je
veux dire simplement c'est donc le fait
que ce débat puisse avoir lieu monter un
vrai malaise qui a un malaise autour de
ce conflit que des gens peuvent
s'identifier
d'un côté de l'autre et que donc je
pense très clairement aujourd'hui encore
c'est que si on veut arrêter ce
processus qui est en train de détruire
le peuple palestinien et qui tend aussi
en train de détruire le peuple israélien
parce que ce qu'on fait en train de
détruire deux peuples qui sont
condamnées de toutes façons à vivre
ensemble dans les années à venir et que
donc pour ça il faut commencer par un
geste c'est le geste du plus fort qui
doit se retirer des territoires
je pense monsieur le fond dames sont
d'accord c'est moitié aujourd'hui le
plus fort mansare peu rigolo pour éviter
de te faire chier trop longtemps les
gens les gestes du plus fort je vais
dire et je le connais parce que aussi
j'ai sur les crémants mon spectacle
cheveux et qui tuent 25e là ils ont fait
une expérience à et des singes qui est
extraordinaire c'est beau c'est pour ça
qu'il faut absolument raconter cette
histoire à ce moment là on met un gros
singe dominant dans une cage
et puis on met un petit couple donc un
singe dominant avec sa femelle le gros
singe
dominant tourner le dos aux couples
parce qu'il sait qu'ici jette seulement
un regard vers la femelle le petit les
tout petits mais c'est un dominant donc
il va lui sauter à la gueule même s'il
va il court vers sa mort il va lui
sauter à la gueule
le gros le sait on est bien dans le
conflit dont on parlait tout à l'heure
une question de dignité
le gros celui qui alarme et le gros le
plus fort tourner le dos
il ya un moment les scientifiques
mettent de la bouffe et on va pouvoir en
prendre de la graine nous les êtres
humains soit disant les scientifiques
mais de la bouche dans la cage sais pas
si tu vois le le le le mélange détonnant
qui a le pouvoir le cul et la bouffe il
met la bouffe au milieu du petit couple
et le gros singe et ben ils reculent
comme ça ils reculent
il va chercher la bouffe pire vient il
continue à tourner le dos et ben moi le
gros singe je lui dis monsieur au
brossage et d'ailleurs il est là je vais
vous le présenter mais tout ça pour dire
que je conclue en disant on vote on
notera dans cette affaire que tout le
monde a voté la paix à commencer par le
plus fort et que ça je trouve que c'est
une bonne phrase que les êtres humains
que nous sommes ici ce soir peuvent
prendre et je voudrais juste rajouter un
petit truc par rapport à tout ce qu'on
dit l'a12 petit truc
d'abord le racisme peut pas exister
parce qu'il n'ya plus qu'une seule race
d'hommes sur la terre plus qu'une seule
tu comprends non non non le sait pas
bien c'est pas bien reste plus que
l'homo sapiens sapiens il est tout seul
parce que c'est depuis deux ans trois
ans que génétiquement en cas de
transfert d'organes en est souvent
beaucoup plus près d'une africaine ou
d'un chinois que de son voisin de palier
qui aussi blanc que nous ça laisse à
réfléchir et puis on a isolé le génome
humain et il est à 2% du chimpanzé on
n'est pas loin du chimpanzé le chimpanzé
très loin du gorille mon n'est pas loin
du chimpanzé et j'ajouterais pour finir
que je baise les pieds de tous les
pacifistes du monde entier a compris à
commencer par les israéliens et les
américains parce que faut avoir une
sacrée paire de couilles pour être
pacifiste en israël et je leur baise les
pieds et je leur dis merci d
je crois que j'ai
on va en rester là
le débat n'est pas terminé partir non
non non sauf que c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique ce que dit jean marie le
sionisme n'est pas né de la loi du plus
fort il est plutôt d de la loi des
faibles qui se sont rassemblés et qui
ont décidé d'aller retrouver ce qui
était pour eux leur patrie ça s'est
passé comme ça ça a été un mouvement
incroyable
s'il est devenu le plus fort au moment
où il été contredite 3,3 pays surarmé et
dix fois plus armé que il a gagné il
occupait et territoires ça s'est passé
ça s'est passé comme ça c'est parce que
ça parce que c'était qu'il habite un
moment il doit s'arrêter maintenant 25
ans que je raconte ça à moi qu'à un
moment il doit s'arrêter à un moment on
doit partager camon faut qu'enfin sont
là prennent et compte amène pattes on
veut combattre contamine pas son dos
avec une ceinture de bons boutoir autour
du ventre
merci d'être venu répondre à josé bové à
bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant
jacqueline à sonova
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soit
josé bové jean marie bigard bonsoir ina
j'avais donc été choisie naseaux mova
par vendeur bras pour succéder un autre
ami que je salue ici
adriana karembeu voilà donc après
adriana voici in à magnéto serge
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
alors dites moi
vous n'avez pas peur que christian
karembeu vous épouse mais je pense
qu'elle est déjà engagé d'accord alors
le casting était impitoyable il a duré
deux ans imagine le travail deux ans de
travail 500 candidates départ 1 500 ce
qui fait mille nichons bienvenus choisis
dans toutes les grandes
agence de mannequins du monde alors
évidemment davantage pour vous quand
même faut dire c'est que d'habitude les
mannequins ont pas de forte battre in
donc pour vous c'était quand même plus
simple quoi le choix se réduit assez
rapidement non bajeux russe
alors elle est un peu de volume dans
l'objectif marketing l agence qui a
procédé au choix c'est-à-dire rscg
s'était trouvé une femme évidemment
qu'il y avait 90 b c'est ça tout à fait
raison c'est sa 90 b et qui puisse
plaire aux hommes sans énerver les
femmes j'étais énerve les hommes aussi
un
alors c'est vrai que on vous avait faire
des simulations d'interviews télévisées
pour voir si vous étiez à même de faire
ce travail de représentation de la
marque
non c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai non là
c'est votre première interview ouais
c'est vrai ça c'est le vrai main c'est
le rêve j'imagine assez bon c'est là
c'est précisément d'ailleurs fait pour
les femmes qui n'ont pas une très forte
poitrine oui absolument
puisque ça ça rassemble vachement le ça
vous a plu les fleurs que j'ai fait
mettre dans votre loge c'est très jeune
merci beaucoup et moi j'ai eu un plateau
de fromages je signale
c'est à moi tout ça ici un texte passe à
la télé moi aussi j'aime aussi alors
d'ailleurs on va faire la question de
pierre dumayet qui est un grand ancêtre
dans la télévision culturelle fort de
pierre dumayet est ce que il n'a ça
serait pas plus pratique que les saints
soient du même côté que les fesses si
pour le slow vidéo ina vous êtes né dans
la banlieue de moscou
mais très jeune vous avez été envoyés en
sibérie non pas pour des raisons
politiques mais parce que votre père
nicolas y était hospitalisé victime d'un
ulcère à l'estomac et votre maire
catalin a été obligé de travailler donc
voilà partis en sibérie deux ans crée de
la mongolie moi je tous les bons
souvenirs de ça parce que c'est des
rivières les forêts oui avec beaucoup de
montagne l'aria 1 comment comme ça c'est
pas le pic elle n'a pas des montagnes
comme ça d'un coup quand vous êtes
retourné à moscou après ce séjour en
sibérie c'était difficile pour vous de
vous retrouver dans cette vie sous le
régime communiste avec vos parents qui
avait pas beaucoup d'argent alors je
pense que régime communiste c'était très
difficile pour tout le monde pas que
pour moi mais parce que je te jeter
petite fille sihem pas d'eux ici là
inazuma aux vagues que vous avez eu des
problèmes de poitrine à l'intérieur
devient une déficience cardiaque
oui mais c'est pas grave c'est l'âge
c'est avec vous je sais quand
[Musique]
vous avez été opérés ont visité six ans
même cicatrices ouais ou là si vous
aussi vous voir ça veut dire vous êtes
trop près donc à cause de ce problème
cardiaque qui n'a pas de sport pas de
danse et vous rêvez de voyager mais à
l'époque elle rideau de fer vous pouvez
pas sortir en tous les cas pas avec vos
parents et vers 18 ans vous trouver un
nouvel objectif vous commencez les
concours de beauté vous commencez à
gagner des concours de beauté gt1 miss
univers ce concours miss univers ce 1994
au fisc les deuxièmes costume national
et en 97 donc vous venez en france pour
voir une amie à vous qui êtes installés
ici qui s'appelle ludmilla et vous
inscrivez dans une agence tout à fait
vous êtes très très bien informé c'est
ce qu'on me dit souvent le capitaine
flam
mort voilà qu
58 tient au fait tout le monde en parle
bien joué vous faites quoi doute dans la
vie à part montrer vos seins alors
j'aime beaucoup voyagé j'aime tout ce
qui est cinéma tout ce qui est le
théâtre tout ce qui est la rdt et
l'agriculture biologique
j'ai vu un gars dîner j'aime beaucoup
aller à jardiner ouais ouais
ce contrat vous interdit de faire quoi
devenir un garçon
bon je pense important il n'y a pas il
n'a pas de règles il n'y a pas de règles
il faut rester en forme n'est pas en
forme mais en forme là là ça va bah
j'espère est-ce que vous retournez en
réussite temps en temps une à hawaï et
es7 matin j'étais là à bonjour je suis
juste heureux avec quand j'étais en
russie mais midi j'étais au mexique
histoire je suis là comment ça se passe
la russie en ce moment il ya un vrai
culte de la personnalité maintenant
concernant poutine des mêmes des gens
comme une chanson réussi à la gloire de
routine ah ouais magnéto
[Musique]
ausy c'est une chanson qui était intime
et un tube en russie merci bosser avec
nous ina merci à vous
[Musique]
oui
on passe maintenant la rubrique tout le
monde s'en mêle alors beaucoup de mails
donc après la première émission pour
savoir d'abord où est passée laurent
baffie bat laurent baffie il est pas là
parce qu'ils en train de réaliser un fil
son premier film n'est ce pas vous qui
avez passé l'été je vais jouer avant
vous jouez aussi je faire un banquier
oui mais qui accepte hold up à la mienne
donc laurent est en train de tourner son
film était que son film sera tourné il
nous rejoindra voilà doute question
aussi où sont alliés et issia me
demande-t-on elles reviendront si vous
êtes sages un mail de laurent gerra
aussi thierry j'ai hâte de voir jack
lang chez vous j'espère qu'il ne l'aura
pas dans sa poche
bravo laurent et puis à part quelques
regrets des compliments pour le vidéo
sampler mon nouveau jouet
dans tous les cas continuent à envoyer
vos mails pour dire ce que vous pensez
de l'émission je ferai pas tout ce que
vous dites mais enfin en tous les cas
j'en tiendrais compte voilà on pouvait
également poser des questions aux
invités
on a eu beaucoup beaucoup de mails vous
concernant in asobo va 43 mail qui
demandent votre numéro de portable est
ce qu'on peut nous le donne et déçu de
ne pas être portable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
the guardian chaque animateur jack lang
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
jack lang françois dufour et nadja pobel
jean marie bigard jack lang bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous je vais faire un
portrait en creux de vous jack lang
vous ne portait pas de cravate vous
n'êtes pas énarque vous n'êtes pas
ministre de la culture ni l'éducation
nationale vous n'êtes pas mouillé dans
un scandale
vous n'êtes pas dénuée de charme vous
n'avez pas à voter socialiste au
deuxième tour des présidentielles
vous n'avez pas inventé la fête des
mères mais la fête de la musique et la
techno parade et la techno parade
c'était cet après midi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà c'est la techno parade de jack
lang s'est encore plus chiant que la
fête des mères c'est absolument
insupportable
merci donc plus sérieusement jack vous
n'êtes pas ministre on dit que vous êtes
très malheureux quand vous n'êtes pas
ministre est ce que c'est vrai et j'ai
une tête de malheureux n'ont pas mini
c'est à dire quand même pas de chauffeur
pas de secrétaire vient votre femme est
obligée de se remettre la dactylographie
nom alors je sais pas moi y ait un
bouquin qui est sorti l'année dernière
écrit vous le connaissez ce bouquin de
jean-françois monde oh oui ça s'appelle
petite chronique d'un grand ministère
chez flammarion sortie en mars 2002
c'est pas très méchant hein c'est un
livre sur vous même pas pas très méchant
en fait c'est vrai quand même que on en
lisant ce bouquin on voit que vous
preniez quand même un certain plaisir à
être ministre il raconte par exemple
vous arrivez dans une conférence de
presse
alors il explique la mise en scène une
une arrivée de jack lang quand même
légèrement en retard
chemise rose des grandes occasions
accompagné d'une trentaine de personnes
est ce que à quoi nous mais ceux ci leur
a causé que ce n'était pas faux alors
vous n'êtes pas ministre aujourd'hui
jack lang à cause de l'échec évidemment
de lionel jospin au premier tour
vous pensez quoi du retrait de jospin de
la vie politique au soir du premier tour
je dirais que quoi qu'on puisse en
penser sur le plan politique c'est une
décision qui ne manquait pas de dignité
noblesse en arrière elle était conforme
à ce qu'il avait toujours dit il avait
dit si je ne réussis pas à l'élection
présidentielle je quitterai la vie
politique vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
m
j'avais bien aimé cette phrase de dire
aux six mois c'est ce que j'ai un peu
ressenti quand le bateau coule c'est pas
au capitaine de ce bar est le premier
quoi oui on peut dire ça et en même
temps je répète il avait clairement dit
à chacun d'entre nous et puis à
l'ensemble de l'opinion
s'il advient que je ne suis pas élu à
l'élection présidentielle je me
retirerai mais l'a été elle l'a fait
vite quoi mais qu'il a été a été écarté
du deuxième tour il s'est retiré en tout
cas il vous a pas beaucoup utilisé
pendant la campagne présidentielle
lionel jospin ce qui peut être une
erreur non moi je ne serais rien dire de
de désagréable à l'égard d'un homme pour
lequel j'ai beaucoup de respect
même s'il est arrivé parfois qu'il ne
soyons pas toujours en accord
moi je me souviens de ce que disait à
l'époque
[Musique]
donc jack lang vous êtes ici pour la
sortie d'un livre chez perrin qui
s'appelle laurent le magnifique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors le choix de laurent de médicis
n'est pas innocent puisque c'est le
premier à avoir fait de l'art une
ambition politique
croyez-vous jack lang que l'art soit la
dernière utopie et je crois que c'est un
des besoins essentiels de l'être humain
ce besoin de beauté alors au xvème
siècle un l'arrêter dans la tête des
gens il vivait avec l'art sous les yeux
c'était une cité celle de florence
entièrement transfiguré par l'art c'est
un idéal qu'on peut tenter aujourd'hui
le réaliser mais disons que lorsque l'on
quitte le xvème siècle rhin le
quattrocento comme l'italien et que l'on
revient sur terre
ici en europe j'allais dire parfois on
tombe de haut
vous dites dans votre book à la
politique de laurent de médicis vise l
impossible
c'est pourquoi il vit toujours mais je
crois que une la politique n'a de sens
à mesure que si elles vivent toujours
impossible lorsque josé bové qui n'est
pas en guerre qu'ils engageaient
civiquement se bat contre des groupes
multinationaux 7
apparemment un combat inégal david
contre goliath et en même temps il faut
toujours se fixer des ambitions des
horizons qui sont apparemment
inaccessible et qui finissent par être
atteint si on se bagarre sauf que josé
bové vous pensez pas vous que l'art soit
la dernière était repris en politique
la cabane je suis humaniste en politique
mais je pense que dans la vie
effectivement l'art c'est quelque chose
jack lang bis qui embellit moi je pense
aussi qui est aussi une des manières de
porter la contestation de la manière la
plus haute
j'aurais envie aussi comme je suis avec
jagland de le remercier parce que les
deux fois où je suis allé en prison
jacques lang a demandé à téléphoner à la
confédération paysanne téléphoner
attaque pour dire qu'est ce que je peux
faire est ce que je peux être d'un
quelconque soutien
donc j'ai envie de le saluer ici parce
que c'est vrai qu'il ya pas beaucoup
d'hommes politiques qui ont accompli ce
geste et vous savez bien chez mitterrand
et ses amis c'est qu'ils soutiennent
leurs copains ça c'est sûr même en
prison
vous auriez aimé être un prince de la
renaissance jack je suis tellement
heureux de vivre cette époque que je ne
parviens pas à imaginer vivre dans une
autre mais c'est vrai que cette petite
cité de florence rey 7 un miracle
quelques milliers d'habitants
c'est le site et qui n'a même pas
d'accès à la mer devient pendant
presqu'un siècle le lieu de tous les
miracles
l'âge d'or des temps modernes a surgi à
ce moment là songez que l époque où vit
laurent le magnifique c'est verrocchio
c'est botticelli c'est à l'atelier
verrocchio le jeune leonard de vinci
c'est le jeune michel-ange tous étaient
fermés 107 efflorescence alors c'est le
coup de foudre pour la toscane à l'âge
de 15 ans avait été pris d'un amour fou
pour cette région pour florence et sa
région lors d'un voyage en 86 avec
françois mitterrand pour dire la vérité
quand j'ai repris mon premier voyage en
italie adolescents à 15 en france ne m'a
pas immédiatement séduit je n'étais pas
en harmonie immédiate avec
l'architecturé avec l'ordonnancement de
la cité et c'est vrai que mitterrand m'a
aidé à mieux comprendre cette ville ces
trésors son histoire et sa culture
alors quand on lit votre bouquin on
pense beaucoup à mitterrand n'a pas
parce qu'on l'appelait le florentin lui
aussi il était savants comme pic de la
mirandole qui vivait à l'époque de
laurent de médicis
il était machiavélique comme machiavel
qui me suivaient à l'époque de laurent
de médicis aussi y aurait beaucoup à
dire sur ce que vous dites ray et à
propos de marc hamel en particulier on
nous a appris tout cela dans les cours
d'histoire où nous dans les facultés
machiavel n'était pas machiavélique
c'était c'était le premier politologues
comme on dit aujourd'hui il a analysé
aussi objectivement que possible les
mécanismes du pouvoir qui parfois ne
sont pas toujours chapati alors
mitterrand comme laurent de médicis a
voulu faire de sa mort un chef-d'oeuvre
d'une certaine façon et des renvois bien
autour
vous commencez votre bouquin comme ça au
moment de la mort de laurent de médicis
il ya des mages avec des positions qui
rôde un peu comme ça autour du prince
un peu comme les terrains que le docteur
gilbert non là vous vous transposez trop
vous voulez absolument tous rapports
tout rapporter à la période
contemporaine
vous êtes intéressé par laurent médicis
et par mitterrand s'est pas complètement
oui mais zoug revenus de les rapprocher
dans un match ou non
sauf que dans le cas de laurent cette
mise en scène de la mort c'était une
manière pour laurent d'assurer la
continuité de la dynastie et
d'introduire par conséquent la
succession françois mitterrand n'avait
pas cette préoccupation n'a en fait jack
lang est assez fasciné finalement parlé
monarque éclairé non je préfère un
monarque éclairé qui ouvre la voie là de
l'humanisme que nous a été le gars au
cateau 15e sienne un monarque autocrate
et sanguinaire oui si vous n'êtes pas
monarchiste c'est le cas du mans comme
mitterrand secrètement pour vous dis la
vérité secrètement nous moi je n'ai rien
contre les monarchies constitutionnelles
en temps de regarder autour de nous les
pays pas laisser l'auditeur le danemark
la norvège sont les pays ultra
démocratique
alors l'utopie artistique justement de
laurent de médicis est aux antipodes de
l'art du possible de de monsieur
raffarin
vous devez être très malheureux
aujourd'hui dans la france de 2002 non
je ne suis pas d'accord c'est de
constater que au moment même où on
décide d'augmenter de 6 ou 7 % les
crédits militaires et de construire un
porte-avions qui probablement comme tous
les autres sera aussi coûteux
qu'inutiles
je trouve un peu fâché que l'on supprime
l'année prochaine dix mille postes dans
l'enseignement
c'est à dire pour préparer l'avenir des
enfants pour préparer l'avenir les
jeunes et pour moi cette
incompréhensible vous n'êtes pas très
france d'en bas
cette expression à la france d'en bas
est une expression que je trouve
méprisante sur marie vous êtes france
d'en bas
moi je trouve qu'il ya un sujet dont on
ne s'occupe pas qu'il est avant l'école
c'est la déliquescence de la famille
j'en parle d'ailleurs dans mon spectacle
[Rires]
pour moi tous les maux de la terre
viennent de la déliquescence de la
famille et chez dit que les animaux
s'occupent de leurs enfants comme ils le
faisaient ya 3000 ans puis nous on n'a
cessé de s'en occuper
donc que des gosses arrivent à l'école
la violence et tout ce qui se passe dans
les banlieues à l'école est partout
vient du fait que un gosse qui dit merde
à sa mère ou qui dit je t'emmerde à son
père c'est pas le prof ou l'instit qui
va s'occuper surtout par paquet 28 c'est
pas lui qui va régler le problème
donc je crois que moi j'essaierai
d'inciter
les parents à s'occuper à nouveau des
enfants et là je ne parle pas de il ya
trois quatre cinq ou six ans je parle
que depuis à peu près une cinquantaine
d'années on dit carrément le intitulé
les spécialistes le toubib dit même si
vous avez votre ville et c'est le
pleurer il n'y a pas de problème vous
devez aller travailler tout match
maintenant à gosse tu vois ça mais en
deux heures par jour entre la nounou la
crèche le machin ça c'est pas bon les
spécialistes du monde entier disent que
la meilleure maman sur la planète en ce
moment c'est la maman africaine c'est
pourquoi parce que son bébé elle dans le
ventre là sur le ventre après au sein et
quand elle travaille elle sur le dos si
tu veux le quitte pas son enfant
en résumé s'en occupe ouais je vais dire
un truc très simple si est la paix dans
la famille si les enfants respectent les
parents et vice versa tiens la paix dans
la famille à la paix dans le village et
à la paix dans le pays
il a appelé dans le monde c'est très
très globale du contrat par un la bonne
gouvernance
je ne sais pas où il va le sait-il
lui-même quelle stratégie économique
que propose-t-il au pays comme horizon
sur quel levier pour la création
d'emplois pour la craie pour le
développement harmonieux du pays
j'étais peut-être inattentive je ne sais
pas où nous allons je ne sais même pas
où il va et par ailleurs ils ont puisque
vous l'absolu manquons par le politique
moi je considère qu'il mène une
politique de classe politique est
favorable aux puissants aux privilégiés
et ce qui est appelé france d'en bas
pour employer cette expression
elle n'est pas dans ses préoccupations
quotidiennes
alors monsieur aillagon qui demande aux
services publics d'être lui même et
qu'il voulait pour cela monte la
redevance c'est bien ça non la
télévision publique et la radio publique
française manque de ressources
quand vous comparez avec la télévision
et la radio publiques allemandes
britanniques ou scandinaves la
télévision et la radio publiques
françaises ont deux fois moins de moyens
pour exister pour fonctionner pour moins
de pub serait nos impôts pour qu'elle
mène pour qu'ils aient plus de places de
l'argent et il vient de la pub à 50% ce
qui est beaucoup plus de places
accordées à des heures de bonne écoute à
la science à l'éducation à la culture
aux arts a beaucoup de sujets et je
crois que sur ce plan là monsieur
aillagon a posé une juste question est
malheureusement son premier ministre lui
a répondu niet
alors encore un truc là c'est une phrase
de votre livre laurent le magnifique
chez perrin donc été relevé par le
canard enchaîné vous écrivez laurent
devient un héros intemporels en raison
de son intelligence politique et de sa
capacité hors du commun d'illusionnisme
les uns et les autres sur ses défauts
comme sur ses qualités
je suis donc dans le cas d'axa
s'appliquera à vous je laisse le canard
et vous-même libres de le penser bonne
nouvelle pour vous jack lang cette
semaine dans paris match un sondage bv à
paris match vous donne personnalités
numéro un de la gauche 52% des sondés ou
font confiance pour l'avenir
vous serez peut-être président vivons
l'instant présent carpediem va quand
même faire une interview si j'étais
président
à quel pays feriez-vous la guerre ok à
quel pays feriez-vous l'amour je dirais
oui je dirais l'italie et la grèce est
ce que si vous étiez président vous
balade de riez à poil au fort de
brégançon sur suis incapable je me
trouve trop moche qu'un joueur de foot
mettriez-vous systématiquement sur le
terrain je suis pas assez compétent pour
choisir utilisons la nouvelle génération
qui va surgir maintenant si c'est par
exemple à quelle région de france
donneriez-vous son indépendance aucune
mais je donnerai à chacune d'entre elles
le droit d'être elle même ce serait
formidable
et c'est pourquoi j'ai encouragé moi
même ce qu'on appelle les langues et
cultures de france c'est normal on gagne
encore 5
si vous étiez président jack lang
combien y aurait-il de gay pride par an
mais peut-être qu'il y en aurait plus
aucune puisque finalement nous aurions
profondément transformé les honneurs la
vitrine une norme gay pride
comme cholet d'animaux
[Musique]
jack lang si vous étiez prise en main
publique quelle chanson de francis
cabrel prendriez vous comme hymne
national
je ne prendrai pas de chansons comme
hymne national
ouais au fond je garderai notre hymne
national que j'aime beaucoup qui placent
rivaux la culture art je vous mettrai
tout mettre à l'essai ces deux éditions
j'accueille maintenant philippe meyer
[Musique]
il
philippe meyer bonsoir alors fils
pilleurs et écrivain de radio acteurs
professeurs musiciens et vous fumer la
pipe
voilà et comme amy je suis de l'aveyron
et vous publié chez robert laffont
démolition avant travaux
voilà donc c'est un journal de campagne
que vous commencez le 20 avril à la
veille du premier tour des élections
présidentielles et que vous achevée le
16 juin soir du deuxième tour on va
parler d'autre chose parle pas que de
politique alors une première chargée
pour les sondeurs effectivement vous
dites aujourd'hui lénine n'écrirai plus
que faire il commanderait une enquête
d'opinion ces espèces de sondages omani
sa vie de la classe politique oui au
lieu de faire des reportages des
enquêtes d'aller sur le terrain de
passer le temps de voir sache pas pour
les journaux puisque c'est mon métier
autant balayer devant sa porte
les hommes politiques ont d'autres
moyens pour connaître les choses il ya
des études qui sont faites on fait un
sondage alors si on voulait savoir dans
quel état était la france ont fait un
sondage sur le moral des français est le
moral des français est bon et voilà ty
pas que quelques jours après les
français en l'air d'avoir complètement
changé de moral puisqu'il envoie un
message tout à fait différent par les
élections c'est la même chose tout à
l'heure vous parliez à jack lang d'un
sondage de popularité sa glande 2% wii
et sa mesure une chose précise qui est
la popularité jacques lang et populaire
est l'homme le plus populaire de la
gauche d'après ce sondage
mais entre la popularité et
l'éligibilité il ya une très grande
différence envisager la soirée la non
mais c'est comme ça que ça traîne il a
dit qu'il payait candidat j'ai quand
même été élu député du pas de calais et
j'en suis fier
vous savez où c'était le pas de calais
avant naturellement oui très souvent par
exemple bernard kouchner week end
extrêmement populaire il n'a jamais
réussi à se faire élire nulle part ça
n'a aucun rapport là le résultat est là
les galets oui mais enfin y avoir quand
même autant de votants le monde sur un
même fauteuil
voilà donc tout le monde y passe avec
vous vous avez une plume assez acerbe
philippe meyer alors chirac évidemment
jacques chirac
vous dites super menteur devient super
remparts c'est ça c'est ça qui s'est
passé en l'espace de quinze jours à coup
on a vu
paré de toutes les vertus et le
président de la république lui-même
d'ailleurs se convaincre un moment donné
il a il a dit que le combat de sa vie
était un combat contre le contre le
fascisme les idées de le pen
ouais mais enfin c'est une plaisanterie
c'est le président d'un pays n'a rien à
voir avec les idées de le pen tout le
monde le sait et celui ne dirai sont des
menteurs ou des gens qui veulent lui
faire défaut au procès mais le combat de
sa vie n'a rien à voir avec ça ou est ce
qu'il avait comme un singe était de
devenir président il leur est exactement
et je rappelle dans le livre en citant
mes sources que au moment où le front
national a fait élire sa première a eu
sa première victoire électorale c'est à
dreux vous en souvenez c'était une liste
commune entre le rpr qui s'appelait pas
les repères où je crois où c'est plus
flou peu importe et dont chirac est déjà
le leader et qu'à ce moment là quand on
a interrogé chirac il a dit mais si
j'avais été adressée ce que j'aurais
fait alors je sais bien que la politique
ça consiste à avoir des vérités
successives et c'est pas toujours
quelque chose qu'il faut prendre de haut
d'un air de dire faut pas croire qu'il a
pratiqué la morale ce soit la même chose
mais quand tout à coup le président de
la république nous raconte ça et que
tout le monde journaux compris le
regarde sauf un en l'occurence cette
libération
le regard des dix ans mais sûrement oui
oui puisqu'il le dit ce doit il ya
quelque chose qui là dedans est de
l'ordre de la comédie mais qui n'est pas
de l'ordre de la politique c'est à dire
d'essayer de prendre de front les
problèmes qui étaient posées face à
chirac évidemment jean marie le pen
alors vous dites là très clairement et
c'est même un point important de votre
livre la france avec le pen a joué à se
faire peur parce qu'il est pas vraiment
de raison qu'il soit élu non plus on a
parlé de triomphe
16% des voix c'est pas non plus un
triomphe un croire ou faire croire que
les 1 % d'électeurs qui ont voté pour
l'extrême droite sont 20 % de gens qui
adhèrent à l'idéologie nazie
c'est vraiment raconter absolument des
sornettes et prendre les gens pour des
idiots
il ya là dedans un petit pourcentage de
gens qui sont sûrement des nazis fervent
est convaincu il n'y a pas plus de gens
qui sont adhérents au nazisme dans les
électeurs de le pen en juin qu'il n'ya
de gens qui sont adhérents au trotskysme
dans les électeurs de besancenot dans
les électeurs de mademoiselle laguiller
parmi lesquels compte la dame au chapeau
la kiffer les bijoux de famille à mon
avis ne sait pas très bien si trotsky a
poursuivi lanceur russe donc vous dire
quelque chose on a un truc de
l'inspecteur qui pourrait simplement
dire qu'il est tout à fait raison de
penser qu'il n'ya pas 20% de fachos
nazis dans les gens qui ont voté le pen
la diversité des candidats fait que le
pen est arrivée deuxième tour c'est avec
personne l'a vu arriver mais moi ce que
je ce que je ressens c'est que à force
d'avoir que des mecs qui raconte des
conneries tout à force d'avoir tout le
temps que des faux gentil de gauche et
de droite à peu près partout les gens
finiront un jour par préférer un vrai
méchant que des faux gentil moi c'est
comme ça et j'analyse le truc alors vous
continuez donc ségolène royal vous dites
pense que les électeurs devraient
repasser leur examen
c'est assez bien vu c'était assez
honnêtement j'ai pas beaucoup parlé de
ségolène royal il se trouve que elle a
un peu le don de m'agacer donc je les
dis en une phrase mais jouent alors
arlette laguiller vous dites que c'est
la dernière gilbert la plus sectaire d
organisation trotskyste alors c'est
quand même quelque chose tout le monde
sait que cette organisation est
organisée précisément comme une secte
mais ça c'est le la situation à mon avis
très négatif dans laquelle nous sommes
c'est que il suffit d'être médiatisé
pour être à l'abri
au fond il ya une espèce et oui on est à
l'abri on est à l'abri de la curiosité
des journalistes on est à l'abri leurs
les deux frères cohn-bendit se sont
échinés avant les élections a publié
dans libé désertiques pour dire
attention l'arlette ça n'a pas
d'importance qu'à derrière sainz et elle
elle s'est mis à pleurer la télévision
secrète chez vous même je ne sais plus
offert la plus belle aurait pu tuer leur
est dû à l'arrêt du bus c'est l'inter
d'intervenir il ne sort plus sans son
auréole
oui mais mille lastic beaucoup je
trouverais raffarin animal politique
hybride à la fois les
les pieds dans la glèbe et la tête dans
les hautes technologies c'était le
raffarin est un est un croisement en
effet tout à fait inattendue de purs
produits du terroir et de pur produit de
l'internet mais c'est l'internet dans
des savez pour vendre des confitures
soi-disant de grand-mère qui sont
fabriqués dans l'industrie ont fait des
pots avec des faux petit mouche un
machin envie chine mais je le demande
s'il fera pas bientôt vendre des
ordinateurs dans des terrines
ordinateurs du pays l'ordinateur de
terroir et des traditions de
l'ordinateur de l'aveyron josé bové
versa puisque nous sommes quasiment
cousin par l'aveyron alors sarkozy vous
dites mettre en place une politique
répressive classique en l'habillant des
valeurs au nom desquels chirac a fait 82
%
écoutez moi je comprends pas comment on
peut imaginer qu'une politique
uniquement policière même si tout le
monde sait qu'elle est évidemment
nécessaire peut arriver à venir à bout
de ce qu'on appelle la sécurité qui est
pas seulement la délinquance la petite
délinquance est là et la moyenne
délinquance mais qui est aussi le
sentiment qu'il ya plus de repères bref
cette façon de présenter les cités comme
un endroit où il n'ya pas d'êtres
humains mais que des problèmes est une
chose qui est profondément un facteur
d'incompréhension de la société et qui
dit incompréhension de la société dit il
n'y a pas de solution si on vous donne
pas la carte vous savez pas comment
aller dans un endroit
nous on a besoin d'avoir la carte les
journaux devrait nous informer par des
reportages et pas tout le temps par des
positions de curé y en a marre jura et
on a justement à dix meilleurs on arrive
aux journalistes leur serge july je dois
dire que c'est quand même lui le patron
de libération
c'est quand même lui qui est le plus
victime d'un volume de lui même sans un
véhicule cité oui c'est pas ma faute
c'est à dire je n'ai fait que citer ce
qu'il avait écrit si vous voulez les
joues la mégane julie premier roi des
truffes oui à la fin c'est ainsi qu'il a
dit qu'il s'éteint par exemple il a
expliqué après la
nice du 1er mai que c'était le signe que
la gauche allait gagner que c'était le
signe d'une mobilisation citoyenne que
les gens revenaient à la politique qui
revenaient vers les partis etc bref quoi
il a pris ses désirs pour la réalité
et puis surtout c'est là c'est la
tendance commune à l'ensemble des
journaux français julie n'est qu'un
exemple dans la sphère simplement c'est
un exemple particulièrement probant si
je puis dire et facile à illustrer mais
c'est la tendance des journaux français
c'est beaucoup plus facile de faire la
morale que d'aller voir la réalité
d'abord allé voir la réalité on se
frotte les chaussures on va dans des
endroits où il ya des pauvres ya pas de
bons restaurants
il ya des gens de tout un tas brasse qui
parlent tout un tas de langue il faut
revenir essayer de comprendre ce qu'on a
vu tandis que dire aux gens voilà ce que
vous auriez dû faire comment vous avez
fait ça c'est pas bien la grüne presse
salariale et c'est vraiment
l'éditorialiste est encore en oeuvre est
éditorialiste prenez jean françois revel
voilà un vrai ditoriaux lis quand vous
lisez ces éditoriaux vous comprenez des
choses ils vous informent sur les choses
puis après ils vous proposent une
opinion philippe meyer pourquoi il n'est
pas question de jack lang dans votre
livre pour de la veine et je préfère
qu'ils n'aient rien et rayures moore
donc j'ai été pour une fois épargnés la
chanson vous en êtes où ben écoutez ça
n'a pas grand chose avec tout ça mais
j'ai sorti un disque d'ailleurs vous en
aviez parlé dans sur sur une autre
chaîne est et tué ou une chance bien de
chanter les chansons des frères james
park
chanter c'est quoi votre chanson
préférée les frères jacques ma chanson
préférée faire jacques pour vous être
agréable ça va être la plus courte c'est
une chanson qui s'appelle l'amour en 19
ponts et qui sera sa part et qui fait
rien du tout qui lui fait de l'oeil
lui a souri sur le pont marie il ne la
borda que sur le pont de l'alma avait
les redonne jusque sur le pont de l'a 10
ce qui fait beau on solférino il a
répondu oui sur le pont saint-louis il
la trouva belle sur le pont de la
tournelle le trouva baume sur le pont
mirabeau vizille de 20 ans reçu le pont
alexandre et l'a embrassé pont de
l'archevêché
il lui a dit je t'aime sur le pont
bir-hakeim et elle moi aussi sur le pont
bercy il se faisait tard sur le pont des
arts lorsque son mari les vip ont su lui
quatre saisies le rival sur le pont
royal et le bascula pas dessus le pont
d'iéna
je veux suivre mon amant dit-elle pont
de conflent et son corps fif lac par
dessus le pont de tolbiac
elle l'a rejoint à noël sous le pont de
grenelle à jamais réunie sous les ponts
de
paris
bravo c'était la plus courte démolition
avant travaux
philippe meyer c'était l'idée chez
robert laffont madame messieurs
mais
[Musique]
oui il vers merci à bientôt
merci et maintenant cette façon si le
doyon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lou doillon alors lou doillon bonsoir
monde imagine on va éviter de parler de
jane birkin on va éviter de parler de
jacques doillon de charlotte gainsbourg
de lulu gainsbourg et cetera on va
parler un tout petit peu de votre enfant
qui est né le 12 juillet vous aviez
encore 19 ans à l'époque puisque vous
n'avez 20 ans que depuis le 4 septembre
et vous avez vous déjà beaucoup de rues
en france qui s'appelle rue du 4
septembre à cause de vous non ah bon à
cause de quoi là dites moi à cause de
quoi
bcc 4ème république ne suis pas sûr une
400 ans 4e république non ces changement
de république m'a alors laquelle à ben
ouais soit pour être obligés de demander
à jack lang
bon je suis choisi lioran moi aussi je
pense les accords h pour un changement
de régime mais google mais c'est le 4
septembre mais la de messieurs alors ne
te retourne pas vers moi pour moi c'est
là c'est le lendemain du 3 c'est la
veille du sein est ce que quelqu'un ici
c'est pourquoi les russes appellent rue
du 4-septembre maintenant donc ça sera
pour l'anniversaire de lou doillon
c'est bien ce que je dise prêt e à
maintenant je dis pas il faut que les
gens envoient des mails et on va faire
un concours que je le vis tous situera
dans la brèche vous n'êtes pas loin mais
c'est pas ça voilà on va voir la semaine
prochaine j'annoncerai le nom du
vainqueur ou de l'a20 que 2 jusque
maintenant on doit tout mettre au
féminin alors votre petit garçon
s'appelle marleau tieger c'est un peu la
mode des prénoms insensé maintenant chez
les stars n'ont ouais mais en même temps
je trouve ça plus rigolo moi j'ai
toujours aimé j'étais toujours la seule
à m'appeler comme ça à l'école c'était
toujours à sa gamme je trouve ça plus
rigolo comme signé comme jack à l'école
tout mais à l'époque à l'époque on quand
on avait un prénom un peu particulier
c'était pas très drôle ouais non c'est
pas mal à l'école a maintenant c'est
l'inversé
vous avez souffert de ça vous ah bon
j'aurais préféré m'appeler j'arrache
c'est sain c'est un mauvais tour qui
vous ont fait vos parents le monde alors
qui a appelé sa fille lily rose melody
way paradis bayon le souffle pas qui
appeler sa fille lourdes elle madonna
qui avait sa fille chastity une idée
chère qui a appelé son enfant parce
qu'avec un prénom pareil on sait pas ce
que c'est pieper ma rue je sais pas ben
c'est l'agent scully de x files séguy
l'irlande ersonne bizarre comme les
prénoms que les gens vont chercher la
paix de rien un môme piper ma rue vous
qui avez son enfant scout larue
ouais bravo
demi moore et bruce willis bravo et qui
a appelé son enfant txcell j'arrive pas
à le dire m
ist a assez facile ça oui bravo lizarazu
très bien sûr et qui appelait son
enfance au oui bravo david bowie et des
prairies du prénom un bravo bien alors
on va passer à votre autre actu le film
blanche de bernie bonvoisin qui avait
déjà réalisé les démons de jésus et qui
était de mon temps le leader de trust
donc blanche avec vous dans le rôle
titre avec antoine de caunes carole
bouquet roschdy zem jean rochefort
gérard depardieu
le pitch je le fais vous le faites la
saison ben c'est simple c'est l'histoire
globalement et saintes c'est le cardinal
mazarin donc joué par jean rochefort qui
corrompt la france il ya une famille qui
s'opposaient à lui qu'est la famille de
péronne mais cette famille et exterminer
sauf une personne vous c'est un miracle
blanche est sauvé vous êtes recueillies
en secret par le mercenaire qui doit
vous abattre c'est un petit peu comme
dans le conte de la belle au bois
dormant et vous devenez une magnifique
jeune fille prête à tout pour vous
venger
c'est ça non c'est un peu un roman au
départ comme ça le chenal ça fait un peu
roman de cape et d'épée
après on verra que c'est pas
complètement ça on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble manindo une époque
sanguinaires à pouvoir absolu
une enfant meurtri à jamais
aujourd'hui elle veut se venger l'ange
patron est pleine de rage
rendez-vous pour trompette et celle là
des tul apporte au lait je suis passé
pour un pack très solide qu'à deux
doigts de la trappe
on dit même que tu tapes dans la caisse
ça le permettrait pas tais toi [ __ ]
[Musique]
la semaine de tricks de tricks karnataka
béton sac à main
vous en fils de façon non blanches anti
cache aucune descente
voilà blanche de bernie bonvoisin avec
nous voyons dans le rôle titre qui est
notre invité ce soir
alors comme je disais sur un vrai film
de cape et d'épée mais revisité 2002
quand même non au niveau des dialogues
de deux personnages n'a même pas 2002
parce que c'est vraiment l'invention de
bernis tous les dialogues et l'idée de
mélanger des costumes d'époque et pas
vraiment d'époque et de mélanger plein
de style ça ça vient de lui je sais j'ai
pas vu quelque chose comme ça
même aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
d'assez déjanté je coule alors vous
plaignez toujours la presse people mais
c'est comme dans un magazine people que
bernie bonvoisin vous à repérer je crois
qu'ils avaient peur un peu que je sois
trop garçon manqué avant et qu'ils
voulaient vraiment blanche soit une soit
une femme qui se bat mais qu'elle n'est
pas qu'ils soient pas trop un garçon
manqué voulait pas aller dans cette
facilité la et de la rendre un peu
féminine et je crois qu'ils avaient peur
que je le sois pas qu'il a vu certaines
photos qui ont du mépris que je pouvais
l'être
cette fibre et femmes un peu elle avait
tout de suite je sais pas alors comment
vous trouve assez étonnante dans le film
j'ai dû apprendre les scream
l'équitation c'était assez compliqué
pour vous non ben moi je suis pas
sportif du tout mais c'était très très
rigolo c'était vachement mieux on a eu
deux mois de préparation à faire oui
quatre heures des scream 4 heures de
cheval par jour et
et c'était une grande expérience c'est
la première fois que vous avez un
personnage que aussi loin de vous ouais
ouais et où il fallait vraiment touré à
trans et on ne marchait pas pareil il
fallait inventer une nouvelle dégaine
les mots je pouvais pas vraiment faire
de l'improvisation parce que c'était un
dialogue soit cinq fois le tuyau est
très écrit donc on pouvait pas
improviser là dedans il fallait être à
l'aise sur un cheval ou avec une épée
donc il fallait apprendre tout ça mais
c'était je crois que c'est ça qui m'a
vraiment fait comprendre que j'avais
envie de faire ce métier parce que de
voir que je pouvais prendre du plaisir
en jouant des personnages qui me
ressemblait pas du tout ouais est ce que
c'est votre premier film
non non parce que les autres il ya un
vrai travail aussi quand on fait des
personnages qui vous ressemble il ya un
travail d'aller chercher très
profondément et qui est aussi douloureux
que de se réinventer je crois donc c'est
pas mon premier film mais c'est c'est le
premier film
avec un rôle de composition entre
guillemets voilà ouais vous la
connaissez depuis longtemps déjà claude
doyon
vous l'avez vu naître oui je suis vieux
je les lui d'être elle a bien évolué non
aujourd'hui gracieux intelligente et
déjà par elle-même elle donne envie de
voir si voilà c'est une vraie femme
merci merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
merci jacques lange vous laisser filer
merci beaucoup balesi les enfants
aillent partent ensemble à ça les
magazines people vont avoir du grain à
moudre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bientôt et maintenant tout couleur vous
rendez vous va si christine angot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et si longue au bon soir alors c'est que
maintenant les téléspectateurs peuvent
envoyer des mails pour poser des
questions aux invités qui vont venir
dans l'émission c'est sur le site tout
le monde en parle
donc j'ai un mail de christelle de tours
qui dit christine angot seriez-vous
masochiste pour revenir sur le plateau
de thierry ardisson
alors que l'expérience semblait assez
négative
la dernière fois si ce n'est pour vous
en tout cas pour quelques
téléspectateurs
mais je ne vais pas voir thierry
ardisson je vais voir kristen voilà donc
le tout va bien alors pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas vu les épisodes
précédents
voici un petit résumé donc d'abord vous
êtes venu parler ici christine angot de
votre livre l'inceste magnéto serge ira
me page 206 là quand même
c'est violent à l'isi son père l'a forcé
à manger les clémentines sur son sexe
ses l'inceste
il l'a sodomisée seulement après il
allait à la pharmacie acheter de la
vaseline et je voudrais savoir parce
qu'il fait rire david avec clémentine
célarié
c'est parce qu'elle s'appelle clementi
gens ont ri parce que je pensais que je
m'apprêtais ventilé pas d'accord et oui
mais voyez mais son père l'a forcé à
manger des clémentines sur son sexe non
je me suis marré parce que j'ai entendu
les gens rigolaient parce que je me suis
dit tiens énormément on arrête on en
parlait déjà plus d'accord en continu
voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est on
rigole des fois souvent de choses on ne
comprend pas c'est vrai voilà ensuite
christine angot vous êtes revenu pour
votre livre suivant qui s'appelait
quitter la ville livre dans lequel vous
racontez votre premier passage dans tout
le monde en parle entre autres alors
vous dites alors dans votre bouquin en
parlant de sa clémentine célarié menti
fier d'avoir à se justifier à tellerie
angola vue pas le téléspectateur le
public a ri david hallyday a ri ils ont
ri après que thierry ardisson a lu page
206 et c'est ce qu'on vient de voir et
vous continuez
tous ont ri maintenant ils sont gênés
maintenant gêné qu'ils sont les invités
fixe le petit écran qu'ils ont chacun
dans l'invention qui leur permet de
tamiser le réel par sa représentation
clémentine j'ai ri parce que les gens
ont ri parce que je pensais qu'il
pensait à moi
david hallyday on rigole souvent des
choses qu'on comprend pas personne ne
relève et d'émission continue donc vous
aviez jeter un vrai froid voulait dire
avec ce passage oui parce que vous leur
avez demandé pourquoi ils ont ri c'est
vrai que la réaction humaine devant
devant une phrase comme ça c'est une
réaction humaine
j'ai une réaction naturelle contrat
social ouais je fais ça c'est vraiment
un truc soit on dit une phrase qu'elle a
que la crudité de celles que j'ai cité
de votre précédent livre donc s'appeler
l'inceste
les gens rient ce une façon de se
défendre devant une telle violence
exactement je prends bien les gens ont
tort de se défendre parce qu'à force de
se défendre
il ne protège pas les autres et c'est
toujours les mêmes qui sont dans les
places qui sont à la place d'être
attaqué et ça suffit quoi j'en ai marre
mais ce soir là christine angot vous
n'avez pas quitté la ville vous avez
quitté le plateau
et puis à partir de là on essayait de me
draguer mais j'en doute pas refouler
face à voir ce qui aura marqué dans le
prochain bouquin
voilà et est ensuite continué la pétoche
peut-être pas de prochain bouquin stop
ou encore choisi
non stop pourquoi christine je crois
vraiment ça m'amuse pas quoi mais
pourquoi on s'amusait bien ou mal - non
balle est partie 1
voilà christine angot donc dans le livre
que vous publiez aujourd'hui parce
qu'entre nous c'est une vraie histoire
qui dure
c'est un feuilleton donc le livre
s'appelle pourquoi le brésil on va en
parler publié chez stock
on va vous raconter le départ chaque
fois vous raconter les missions
précédentes et vous venez en parler dans
une émission se veut durer pendant
pendant une vingtaine d'années moi je
serais ravi parce que je finis par vous
appréciez beaucoup je vais vous le dire
vous racontez votre départ de l'émission
en fait vous dites ça m'a un petit peu
soulagé parce que j'étais quand même
très culpabilisés par cette histoire
vous dites que en fait vous n'aviez pas
envie de sortir ce soir la détresse est
quand même très très tard je suis
fatigué très fatigué de didier il faut
aller voir
également il faut tout ça enfin bon bref
c'est quand même assez bon maintenant
c'est un espace public un djibril début
et oui ben oui bah oui moi perso je vous
êtes vous êtes dans l'ambiance
j'imagine qu'à voilà bon mais en face
c'est un espace public quand on écrit
des livres c'est la moindre des choses
d'y aller dans cet espace sinon de toute
façon voilà c'est normal quoi
j'espère que ce soir ça se passera mieux
que dans votre prochain livre
vous avez un truc sympa à raconter sur
la soirée de ce soir donc celui-là
s'appelle pourquoi le brésil cet extrait
d'une phrase d'une lettre que vous
retrouvez que votre père vous a écrit
alors il n'y a pas d'histoire avec vous
les lecteurs ont droit à votre parcours
mentale à ce qui se passe vraiment dans
votre tête vous écrivez vous dit un jour
j'ai compris
non parce que l'écriture devait tête
mais ce qu'elle était chez moi c'est à
dire vous êtes contre l'histoire contre
les personnages je suis pas contre j'ai
pas du tout contre mais disons que quand
on raconte quand on est dans le récit
quand on raconte une histoire
à mon avis on forcément on se trompe
parfois ça peut jamais être ça peut
jamais être très juste quoi donc la
seule chose qu'on a à faire c'est ce
qu'on a entendu comment ça s'est passé
dans sa tête qu'on a ressenti qu'est ce
que c'était qu'est ce qu'on a ressenti
quand on la rencontrait telle personne
ce qu'on a éprouvé parce que en fait
dans la vie on ne fait que ça quand on
quand on parle quand on arrive à parler
de manière un peu intime avec quelqu'un
qu'est ce qu'on lui dit ben oui tu vois
il est arrivé il m'a dit ça et ça m'a
fait ça on passe notre vie à dire ce
genre de choses c'est de l'auto fiction
ça vous embête quand on est au tourisme
oui parce que si vous voulez une
autofiction c'est quand même faire de
soi un personnage un donc autant dire
une caricature est baladé ce personnage
dans une histoire de conte en dire une
caricature de vie donc moi j'aime vous
appelez ça comment alors au tour à
comptage moi j'appelle ça roman parce
que je pense que c'est écrit dans la
langue qu'on parle plus alors ça
fonctionne assez bien je dois dire j'ai
lu ce bouquin j'étais assez pris je les
vis d'une seule traite c'est on rentre
dans votre tête quoi on se rend compte
que c'est pas simple d'ailleurs d'être
dans la tête de christine angot
vaud dans la vôtre c'est plus simple à
sucre meubles c'est vrai a quand même
oui j'avoue déçoit non mais ça m'étonne
mais c'est bien ça alors il aventures de
christine angot maintenant c'est un peu
comme martin alors il ya christine angot
c'est pas tout à fait comme c'est pas
tout à fait mais y'a un côté comme ça si
les aventures de christine angot vous
employez beaucoup de noms propres cas
personne qui n'est pas son vrai nom dans
votre ci a bien une personne parle pas
son vrai nom
je sais pas qui c'est mais vous dites
vous en plus nombreux à vous dit si on
veut écrire il n'y a pas de demi mesure
si vous voulez bien sûr que non il n'y a
pas de demi mesures ou alors il ya des
demi livre est donc bon
voilà ouais moi vous êtes quand même pas
toujours fidèle à votre dogme a par
exemple par les pattes de votre fils est
au nord dans le bouquin ou très peu à
peu passer par là c'est pas c'est pas la
question donc ça c'est de la demi-mesure
un peu non non non pas du tout là c'est
vraiment c'est pas assez
c'est pas ça que je regardais c'est pas
ça que j'avais à résoudre à ce moment là
alors je ne parlais pas beaucoup donc de
vote il parlait pas beaucoup de chèques
ça vous dit je sais pas raconter je ne
sais pas raconter effectivement le sexe
et quand il n'ya pas quand il n'ya pas
de quoi il ya un rapport d'égalité je
serai raconté le sexe quand il ya un
rapport d'inégalité parce que s'il ya un
rapport d'inégalité et de contraintes
vous êtes obligé de séparer votre corps
et votre tête et dont vous pouvez garder
de la place dans la tête pour savoir ce
qui s'est passé est ce que vous avez
ressenti alors que je pense que sinon
quand vous êtes dans un rapport sexuel
bon sans contrainte enfin bon voilà
harmonieux je sais pas quoi et bien à ce
moment là vous n'avez pas besoin de
faire cette cette séparation la caisse
comme marcher ensemble ce que vous dites
sur le sex magik yaya diallo raconte une
histoire d'amour je suis cash liée à ça
il n'ya pas grand-chose ya ça glisse et
elle sait que c'est dur de votre la base
de votre amant voilà c'est tout ça
glisse et sais que c'est dur ça se
résume à sa remarquable non c'est ce que
je puisse aussi comme les led de votre
père que vous retrouver lors d'un
déménagement sur un peu c'est un peu
monter ses romans c'est ça quand même
non pas du tout ah bon ça ne mens pas je
me vois pas du tout en train de
fabriquer suis pas sûr si vous fabriquez
parce que le dîner branché à la fin il
ya les bd tout d'abord j'ai pas du tout
vulgaire copié dans jalouse l'ajustement
j'ai pas fabriquer jeu les recopier les
hôtels qu'elle j'ai pas changé une
virgule
voilà et si on me dit mais tu n'y étais
pas où vous n'étiez pas effet urgent de
fait je n'étais pas m'en faire j étais
vous savez quand les trucs passe à la
télé je veux dire on y est
donc c'est public ce sont des choses qui
sont publiques donc j étais
nécessairement alors donc comme je
disais n'y a pas d'histoire au sens
traditionnel d'humour il ya quand même
une histoire d'amour avec un critique
littéraire dont vous donner le nom donc
on peut le donner qui s'appelle pierre
louis rose ines quand je vois maintenant
ce que vous lui faites vivre ça me venge
de tout ce qu'il a écrit sur moi il a
accepté facilement de voir son vrai nom
dans le livre
ouais vous dites ça aurait été plus
violente si je devais appeler dupont oui
donc il est content oui je pense
au bout du compte enfin il rentre dans
l'histoire la littérature en même temps
oui enfin vous savez je suis pas sûr que
ce soit les préoccupations enfin
peut-être que si enfin j'espère que si
le jeune veut dire si vous souhaitez
trouve en tout cas c'est quand on vit
avec un écrivain ça peut vous arriver en
tous les cas c'est pas le genre
d'histoires d'amour comme ça qui
transfigure la vie mais c'est vraiment
la dissection d'un rapport amoureux une
espèce de ces anti mythologie de l'amour
c'est dire que absolument c'est anti
mythologie de l'amour ça ne transfigure
pas la vie mais ça permet de la vivre
c'est à dire que au début du livre est
bien bon voilà ça commence
il y en a pas il n'y a pas d'amour il
n'y a pas de rencontre il ya personne
ils viennent pas ou alors sylviane ça va
pas et puis voilà et puis finalement ben
ça se passe
et au moment où il y avait personne
c'était plus possible c'est à dire que
la vie était difficile et écrire par
exemple je me disais que c'était une
chose que je pourrais plus faire parce
que de venir chez vous par exemple en
annonçant que c'est quand même difficile
donc si j'ai personnes quand je rentre
chez moi c'est quand même vraiment
difficile et ça c'est je ne sais pas si
les gens y pensent
en tout cas ça va se vendre comme des
petits pains vous le savez non non je ne
sais pas je n'ose pas le savoir si ça va
être un énorme succès ça se fait à côté
pourquoi c'est ce qu'on me dit mais
jaccottet durassien côté de la manche
c'est dire que ça vous embête gens me
disent ah non j'ai pas partir non mais
en face on vous le dit pour que ça
m'embête donc ça durera c'est bien
oui bien sûr c'est bien mais cela dit
c'est pas du tout dur à ce que justement
duras c'est quand même question
mythologie de l'amour
elle a contribué oui je vais dire donc
je pense que je contribue pas à ça ça va
se vendre les gens dont vous aimez ça
vous embête qu'on vous aime pourquoi ça
m'embête je sais pas peut-être c'est
bien d'être belle être aimé non mais ça
c'est le plaisir extatique de désert si
on est dans la pose effectivement c'est
bien c'est bien te dire personne ne
m'aime cetera bon cela dit moi j'ai
jamais pensé que personne ne m'aimaient
tous les cas des critiques sont
excellentes
j'ai pris juste les mauvaises critiques
parce que il y en a 3 de mauvaises
graisses est surtout de bonnes donc il
ya murray dans le figaro magazine qui
compare votre clivages c'est mon choix
ces espèces de de culte du nombril c'est
très blessant
c'est désagréable pas vous dire que j'ai
dit ça et que vraiment ça m'est égal
mais bon si vous voulez c'est ils sont
renvoyés eux-mêmes et donc ils disent
que ces nombreux lib bah oui seulement
c'est l'heure de l'ombrie c'est tout
alors il ya le magazine gay têtu qui
vous reprochent en sache pas bien
compris c'est sûrement m'expliquer qui
vous reprochent d'avoir écrit il y avait
deux homosexuels dans l'immeuble à côté
qui promenait leur chien
oui qu'est-ce que ça aggrave d'écrire ça
non mais parce que pour enfin je pense
que c'est ils m'aiment bien mais je veux
dire mais il avait besoin d'eux qu'on
discute de ça parce que pour eux c'était
problématique de voir que c'était le
cliché justement le cliché des
homosexuels avec le chien il de felco
terme s il ya des clichés partout il ya
des clichés effectivement dans l'amour
il ya des clichés dans la communication
il ya des clichés
chez les hétéros il ya des clichés chez
les homos on a eu notre critique qui est
plus terrible celle là c'est toujours ce
fameux pierre assouline d'en lire que
l'année dernière à la même époque avait
sorti la fameuse interview de
houellebecq où il attaque et les les
musulmans alors lui dit que c'est pas
une histoire d'amour fou c'est une
histoire de fou mais pas des vrais fous
fascinant dit il des petits fous urbain
de simples caractériel là où la raison
actuellement ce ne sont pas des grands
fous ouais d'ailleurs ça devrait
rassurer tout le monde ce sont des
petits footballeur ben voilà comme nous
sommes tous
et voilà et c'est ça qui que moi je
trouve un bien sûr c'est l'histoire de
petits fours urbain nature avait grand
fou alors ils vous reprochent comme de
parler d'érotisme de la chambre à gaz
puisque pierre louis rose inès vous dit
de lui enfin il dit lui même qu'il est
le seul juif qui se cache en temps de
paix et que vous faites l'amour dans un
appartement rue du four c'est que si le
pen avait écrit ce que vous avez écrit
là non il ya trop de trucs de sujets du
four etc
enfin c'est tout à fait autre chose je
crois que la personne n'importe qui
ouvre ce livre n'importe qui le lie et
tombe raide en se disant mais comment
est ce qu'on a pu dire que c'était
antisémite je sais pas quoi mais
n'importe qui n'importe qui la personne
la plus de mauvaise foi bon c'est
vraiment c'est celle inverse c'est tout
le contraire c'est l'idée qu'il faut
quand même pas oublier que d'en tomber
amoureux de quelqu'un il ya le mot
quelqu'un et que et bien quelqu'un a une
origine que quelqu'un est né quelque
part où quelqu'un n'est pas né quelque
part ou et juifs ou à une famille qui a
été décimée ou pousser ou pas où et
c'est donc la question de l'origine dans
l'amour un ace qui les bras ce qu il est
blond a skié comment les yeux maintenant
les cils recourbés par exemple eh bien
ça oui c'est à dire tous les détails
physiques sont importants pourquoi parce
que c'est beau parce que c'est moche
parce que ça rattache à l'histoire
profonde des êtres c'est tout donc bien
sûr que la peau et ça je vois pas qui va
me dire le contraire que la peau que le
sang c'est profondément érotique
oui et je vois pas pourquoi les juifs
seraient les seuls à ne pas avoir le
droit d'avoir un érotisme c'est tout
très bien christine hodeau pourquoi le
brésil
chez stock
alors on parler de scandale
il ya un la rentrée 2002 de livres qui
ont fait scandale c'est rose bonbon de
nicolas jones corp l'un est il entrerait
dans la légende de louis skorecki le
premier de ces livres là était chez
gallimard et nous invitons maintenant un
membre du comité de lecture de gallimard
qui a accepté donc la publication de
rose bonbon
voici jean marie laclavetine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
réconciliés depuis les pivots on s'est
pas revu
c'est une bonne occasion de vous revoir
donc pour parler de ce problème avec
nous j'appelle un autre écrivain eric 9
[Musique]
il
voilà donc on va commencer en parlant du
livre de nicolas jones borlin et du
livre de louis skorecki le premier
s'appelle rose bonbon le deuxième il
entrerait dans la légende alors à parler
de celui que vous avez édité chez
gallimard un rose bonbon que raconte le
livre en quelques mots le livre c'est le
monologue d'un pédophile qui est pendant
une certaine période de sa vie observe
simplement les petites filles dans les
cinémas et puis un jour passent à l'acte
et donc le livre nous montre ce qui se
passe ce qui est censé se passer à
l'intérieur de la halle tête d'un
pédophile
voilà je précise quand même que le livre
n'est pas du tout un livre réaliste
c'est un une sorte de de compte assez
cruel assez grinçant qu'on peut trouver
drôle moi j'ai personnellement trouvé
plutôt hilarant et avec un sujet qui
bien entendu ne fait pas rire tout le
monde
l'auteur l'auteur est un jeune homme
d'une trentaine d'années qui s'appelle
nicolas jones guerlain est ce qu'il ya
eu des discussions agitées au sein du
comité de lecture de gallimard au monde
publication de ce livre enfin là on
devait cas de la décision de le publier
il s'agit peu au comité de lecture on
discute calmement mais c'est vrai que
certains étaient un peu heurtée par le
sujet même du livre et
d'autres
penser que le livre était suffisamment
intéressants sur plan littéraire pour le
propose à un public
donc vous vous étiez pour la publication
du livre il est publié à un moment il ya
une plainte d'une association de
protection de l'enfance gallimard a
arrêté de servir les libraires puis à
recommencer en mettant un petit leaflet
à l'intérieur du livre pour prévenir les
gens
voilà ce qui s'est passé c'est que
l'association a eu vent de la
publication de ce livre avant qu'ils
soient publiés avant la date de
publication qui était le 26 août donc
une semaine avant l'enfant bleu le nom
de cette association envoie une lettre
de protestation à gallimard en disant
voilà vous n'avez pas le droit de
publier sa arrêté mille attenant
gallimard a publié ce livre malgré tout
à la date à la date prévue
et comme le l'association continuer à
protester nous avons décidé enfin la
maison d'édition a décidé de de calmer
le jeu et de dire qu'on le discute on
essayons de voir qu est ce qu est ce qui
vous choque là dedans de l'acia
et on a arrêté la de servir les
libraires provisoirement il a toujours
été entendu que c'était provisoire est
bon qu'on a vu qu'il n'y avait pas
d'arrangement possible que ces gens là
avaient décidé d'aller jusqu'au bout de
leurs plaintes pour des raisons qui nous
paraissaient qui nous paraissent en tout
cas moi assez scandaleuse le livre est
ressorti en librairie donc je livre est
vendu actuellement oui pareil pour le
livre de scorer qui il entrerait dans la
légende aux éditions léo cher eric vous
avez lu ses livres
oui à cause de vous un rêve moi c'est
des livres qui me choque beaucoup parce
que ça me fait perdre mon temps et ça je
trouve ça grave et mais je trouve très
bien qu'un éditeur défendre un livre
qu'il publie c'est la moindre des choses
et c'est pas toujours le cas
cela dit je trouve que ce livre est un
livre dégueulasse mal écrits sur tout ce
qui est le plus grave péché pour un
livre tellement mal écrit qu'à la fin on
nous fait le coup d'une journaliste qui
aurait retranscrit les propos d'un type
qui sait pas très bien parler français
et moi j'explique ça c'est un garçon qui
avait déjà écrit un livre qui s'appelait
poupée sur les mêmes terrains c'est
brett easton ellis qui fait un mal
considérable aux écrivains français qui
s'imaginent pouvoir faire la même chose
que lui
alors avec de la mort hamas était la
mannequin et poupées de ce monsieur
il s'est dit que moi je faut que je
fasse mon american sicko à moi je vais
trouver un sujet porteur c'est la
pédophilie mais c'est vraiment un livre
petit bras il est pas à la hauteur c'est
un talent faible il ya des sujets faut
être vraiment très très fort pour s'y
attaquer ça on our à n'importe quelle
page est encore plus le livre de scorer
qui c'est à vomir
moi je ne suis pas du tout pour
l'interdiction de ces trucs là l'erreur
des associations de parents lahoud et de
protection de l'enfance c'est d'avoir
braqué un projecteur sur des choses dont
personne ne parlait ces livres là n'ont
eu aucune critique dans les journaux
littéraires et le milieu et un stylet
pédophilie plus talent c'était pas un
béni tout le monde se serait arrivé
dessus là on est dans les rubriques
faits divers ou société c'est quand même
un signe
je pense que ça il faut le traiter par
le silence et par le mépris le problème
c'est qu'il ya une confusion délibérée
qui est faite entre la création il
nerfs et la réalité dans ce que disent
les avocats de cette association et la
présidente de l'association a quelque
chose de vraiment effrayant qui fait
penser aux ligues de vertu au
puritanisme le plus le plus terrible le
plus dur c'est l'inquisition c'est à
dire ils disent les mots sont aussi
graves que les actes
l'avocat le dis en tout les trains il
dit si ce livre était un témoignage si
vraiment monsieur jones berlin avait
fait ce qu'il raconte ça aurait une
valeur documentaire mais là il n'a pas
fait c'est la fiction on peut pas
supporter ça est-ce qu'on ne supporte
pas c'est le plaisir qu'on a justement à
lire des histoires qui sont terribles
qui sont horribles
le plaisir que l'homme fait que l'être
humain a interrogé le mal le côtoyer à
le voir en lui mais c'est le rôle de la
littérature d'observer le mal
aussi si on enlevait des rayons des
libraires tous les livres qui traitent
du mal mais il ya une littérature et des
bons sentiments
alors que ça soit de la mauvaise
littérature sa session de discussions
jean marie vous trouvé ça choquant la
publication de ce livre chez gagne large
et 1 pas n'importe qui mais je trouve
que l'évocation de quelque chose qui est
justement mal même s'il ne correspond
pas un fait divers et de charger de se
charger avec un mauvais sentiments ou de
regarder ou de lire ou de se laisser
imprégner par quelque chose de mauvais
pour moi même si vous pensez à moi que
je suis peut-être vous qui serez censuré
dans ce cas peut-être mais si on me
demande mon avis je le donne comme tout
simplement et je dis que je ne pense pas
que ce soit positif
je ne pense pas que ce soit bon et que
ce soit positif que ce soit profitable
et je pense qu'il faut mieux
toujours dans tous les cas voir le bien
pensé le bien et faire le bien
au maximum donc certainement pas fermer
les yeux
non parce que justement les le l'oeil
est attiré par le pape à toutes les
mauvaises choses c'est ça qui est
fascinant c'est certainement ce que vous
vendez les certainement fasciné par ça
un livre ce ne sont pas des mauvaises
choses c'est un lit oui mais je suis
assez d'accord sur l'idée qu'une chose
mauvaise qui est lui fait que en
engrange dans son coeur quelque chose de
mauvais je pense que quand on achète un
pistolet par exemple je pense la même
chose et je suis pas une grenouille de
bénitier spécialement mais je pense que
on dit ce qu'on a dans la main on l'a
dans le coeur et que le mec qui me dit
qu'un pistolet sle fois ça peut sauver
la vie parce que ça peut te défendre
contre quelqu'un qui voudrait tout les
jeudis non pistolet ça a jamais donné la
vie ça prend la vie un pistolet calibre
celle des deux pistolets non un livre
c'est les mots sont très très importants
c'est pas le contraire d'un pistolet et
que c'est avec des livres qu'on arrive à
faire faire à des tas de gens des choses
horribles
on peut les embrigader faire des mots
qu'on fait remarquer
c'est mon avis et c'est justement pour
prendre le contrepoint de jean marie
bigard là j'ai dans les mains un livre
qu'on m'a prêté qui est un livre qui a
été interdit après la guerre parce qu'il
parlait du pacifisme pendant la guerre
c'était un sujet honteux en 46 quelqu'un
qui rame ne parle pas de sa moyenne avec
des bonnes choses la mer français oui
mais doit on est d'accord mais le
problème c'est qu'effectivement ce livre
a été censurée raconte jamais jamais
dont deux comme refait josé non-droit
siècle là on pourra pas dire que ce
livre évoque des bonnes pensées non mais
je mangeais dans cinq dans la main quand
milan avait dû à la question de la
censure
en fait elle correspond à une idéologie
d'un moment oui il joue crois qu'en
terme de littérature on peut pas si tu
veux faire d'exception où on accepte
effectivement la liberté totale de
l'écriture et à partir de là il ya des
étudiants qui édite les cassettes
pédophiles donc c'est pas lui céder
cassel casse un peu de finition n'est
que du bout ce que l'heure n'est
absolument pas dans la liste de paie de
filles pensent que la cassette on n'est
pas dans la création et en plus on
instrumentalise cependant on
instrumentalise des enfants là c'est la
personne qui est écrit c'est 100 dans sa
tête que se passe le roman et qui le
remet sur le papier c'est à personne
elle même qui efface au sujet dans une
cassette pédophiles ou n'importe quel
cas c'est de ce type là d'exploitation
sexuelle on a exploitation de la
personne et donc on intervient et en
exploite c'est complètement différent en
ce sens avec la création au jour le jour
ou la littérature comme le souhaite
monsieur bigard véhiculera les bonnes
pensées il n'y aura plus que des
catéchismes sur les étalages des
libraires mais le monde sera pas
meilleure pour autant non pas forcément
par exemple ce serait mieux d'apprendre
aux enfants de dire un paysan avait dix
vaches ils sont fait voler deux combien
est lui en reste
eh ben je préfère règle dans l'éducation
aux 10 un paysan v10 vaches il en donne
deux
à son fils combien il lui en reste c'est
ça que je veux dire je préfèrerais qu'on
passe par le positif mais ça ne ça
n'exclut pas qu'on puisse parler des
défauts des hommes
je ne fais rire qu'avec mes défauts on
ne fait rire qu'avec les défauts des
hommes on ne fait rire qu'avec le
malheur on ne fait pas rire avec le
bonheur là c'est moi qui vous en parler
je suis un spécialiste
je vous garantis que le bonheur fait pas
rire à la fin du film quand les deux
amants se retrouvent enfin et
s'embrassent tout le monde est en larmes
dans le cinéma personnes n'éclate de
rire devant le bonheur c'est le malheur
qui fait rire donc je connais bien le
véhicule si je peux me permettre un mot
en présent mais pour médiocrité merci
beaucoup merci d'être venus et rigueur
vous restez avec nous pour le blind test
pour la basse et au blind test
[Musique]
ce soir blind test spécial météo et aux
platines masia félipe corte
c'est dire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon jouer avec nous j'accueille le
vainqueur de la semaine dernière et le
vainqueur de la saison dernière voici
gaël leforestier et pascal sellem
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien qu'on soir donc il ya du lourd ce
soir ça va être chaud le blaze attention
spéciale météo c'est normal en ce moment
vous savez comment on fait philippe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis bien d'accord je veux la terre
près je veux l'interprète film
j
[Applaudissements]
il ment
il
il est mort il est mort pascal sellem 2
les autres 0-1 l'om
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ll
[Applaudissements]
sur france 2 maintenant n'engage plus
que des animateurs qui sont forts au
blind test
attention philippe gilbert non
[Musique]
tout le cas
ok là
[Musique]
si je reconnais mais je reconnais après
moi je reconnais qu un demi point de
2000 points pas de demi point pascal
c'est choquant du lavoir tiers philippe
troubles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les vacances la coïncidence est pas le
blind test christine angot ne
connaissait pas la crise il reste pas si
longtemps dans les logiciels se régale
et là je découvre une autre dimension de
cette édition avec les bons non je n'y
arrive pas j'aime voir sourire en tous
les cas christine philippe bonan l'air
[Musique]
les trois jours
oui
wait for me
[Musique]
et oui souffre l'afrique souffre le
moins contre et là c'est bien parce que
pascal vous aviez dit demis roussos mais
en fait c'est le groupe des demis
roussos eric naulleau qui connaît aussi
bien l'oeuvre des demis roussos que
celle de bret easton ellis bravo eric
nov
on continue philippe guez
messieurs
[Musique]
les avances à des caennais qui fait du
mieux que tu continues à jouer à
l'ajustement génie mais franchement si
la bulle et qu'il regarde la tête de
josé et paix suppose qu'il a la tête
d'un gars qui pense qu'il va gagner chez
lui aucun suspect c'est scandaleux
bob marley
[Rires]
philippe passage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yannick noah papa papa parce que moi je
m'amuse à faire des chansons de brassens
en changeant la musique par exemple sur
l'air de l'orage je te fais la supplique
trempe dans l'encré bleue du golfe du
lion trompeuse trempe sa plume aux
mondiaux tabellion et de ta plus belle
écriture e92 ce qu'il faudrait qu'il
advint de mon corps lorsque mon âme lui
ne seront plus d'accord que sur un seul
point la rupture une robe à talonner les
douze albums parker par deux fois merci
[Musique]
à l'effort comme c'est quand même je
pense que tu es le plus non mais c'est
trop fort un plongeoir
alors toi tu es fort mais pascal est
plus fort philippe
[Musique]
qui sait ça j'ai pas s'aggraver
sa vie des êtres humains et moi on
résiste en mai
amano
mais au monde
c'est bien quand même
la marque et de maintenant mesdames et
messieurs voici le super banco le
gagnant du super banco a tout gagné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g bâle 15 c'est incroyable mais mais
mais big c mais au delà du super banco
il y a non mégabanques au fip que
françois n'a de merde josé raymond vall
a list of now
on se dit fort
messieurs 1
vatin donc le grand gagnant de ce blind
test n'est pas pascal sellem mesdames
messieurs
mais françois dufour d'attac bravo merci
à tous et est où l'on entend des
missions dites est ce que ça va jean
marie bigard les animaux et john ont
tourné l'an
à mon avis
elles sont posées que paris
josé bové et françois dufour le gagnant
du globe baisse le
chez plon kinase au bras merci d'être
heureux de vous avoir connu on
jack lang le rôle magnifique
ces deux émissions verra jagland lors
magnifique
son père a eu le meilleur
mission avant travaux décès robert
lafont lou doillon blanche bernie
bonvoisin avec 10 voyant rouge dizaine
antoine de caunes changement dans le
bouquet josé garcia gérard depardieu
ça sort le 18 septembre
[Musique]
merci d'être resté et sinon pourquoi le
brésil c'est ton émission scott yann
arthus bertrand pour la liberté de la
presse au produit de reporter sans
frontières voilà c'était tournant pas ce
rendez vous samedi prochain
[Musique]
oui je les
je l'aimé
on fait
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
g
[Musique]
et
l'eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]